programming throwdown episode 130 ethical hacking with ted harrington Take it away, Jason. Hey, everybody. So this is a super, super exciting episode. I think I remember, and I'm totally drawing a blank, but there was, I remember some movies from the 90s, you know, about hacking. And, you know, when I got into computing, you know, when I was in high school and middle school, there weren't a lot of folks who are into it, you know, at least in my neighborhood, in my area. And everyone thought that that was hacking, like, oh, you know how to program. Does that mean you can just, you know, plug into this ATM and take all the money? And sadly, I've never been able to do that. But it would be pretty awesome if you could just get money that
easily. But I've always had a fascination with it. I think that it's an intersection of so many different disciplines, sociology, psychology, computing, networking, so many different areas. And we've wanted to do this episode for a really long time. I'm so excited that we have Ted Harrington, who's number one bestselling author and a partner at ISE, who's going to explain all about hacking and ethical hacking and what that all means. So thank you so much for coming out to the show, Ted. Yeah, thanks for having me, guys. Cool. So let's maybe just start with a bio on you. So how did you get into this industry, and what was the path that led you to ISE, where you're at right now? It's funny you mention hacking ATMs, because there was this funny thing that happened in college.
This is a little bit tangential, but it will color the picture a little bit. I went to school in Washington, DC and it doesn't matter that it was DC. I went to college and ATM on campus. And I remember there was this thing that happened one time where there was a bug in the software where whatever the denomination was that you typed in, the ATM actually spit out four times that. So like people were putting in, you know, $100 that they want to take out and they were getting 400. And so of course, you know, once the word spread about this, like the whole student body went and like emptied this ATM. It happened in like an hour. And I remember that time, it sort of struck me, but it was one of these seeds of a thought that stayed in the back of my mind. I didn't really do anything with it at the time, but was, wow, software really runs everything.
And when the software bugs out, really bad things can happen. And it's kind of interesting to think that that was how I rolled. I was in college, I don't know, 20 or something. And fast forward to many years later, that is my profession now is not specifically necessarily robbing ATMs, but helping companies who are building things using software to make sure that stuff like that doesn't happen. And I first got into it about 10 years ago when I met a guy who has become my business partner now. And at the time, we were just talking about some of the things he was doing with his business. And I was talking about things I wanted to do with my life and some of my principles and philosophies. And it was like
the perfect marriage. I'm driven to do difficult things that matter in the service of others. I want to get better every day. Those are are kind of some of my defining principles. And those are the principles that are required to succeed in security. And so once I sort of found that, it was like, this is what I got to do. And I've since dedicated my entire life to it. And now I'm in the position that I get to lead some of the smartest group of ethical hackers ever anywhere. And that's what we do all day is
help companies build better and more secure systems. Wow. Super, super cool. So I have a similar story. It's not my story, but I'll share it anyways. And Patrick, you also took this. We both took VXWorks training, probably at different times, definitely different times. But Patrick probably just breezed through it. I was having trouble. I hadn't done any embedded stuff. And so I was working my way through it. But I remember the instructor saying that he noticed the gas dispenser at a gas station was running VXWorks. And he noticed it because it had a certain JTAG kind of connector and he just connected in and got a VX works terminal. And he found that the price of gas was literally just called price of gas. And it was a global variable in the program. So he just,
he just changed it to zero, uh, pumped his gas for free. And then, and then went back and like, you know, reported it to whatever, you know, uh, multinational was running that gas station. But yeah, it does sound like the early days of computing was sort of this wild west. And then through a lot of work done by people like you, the security has just become a lot tighter now. And there's a lot more on the line now than there used to be back then when things weren't as so tightly connected as they are now. And there's a lot more on the line now than there used to be back then when things weren't as so tightly connected as they are now. Yeah, I would actually maybe even challenge the
assumption that things are tighter now because this is going to sound contradictory. They are and they aren't. So what's really good that we see happening all over the place is that where the efforts of the security community, the security research community, the ethical hackers, like where those of us that are really driving and pushing for this type of improvement in security, where we focus our efforts, it is changing. Like things are getting better. But the problem is that the world, I mean, we're talking about the entire planet is so relentlessly adopting software to replace previous processes or systems sometimes that were often very done manually or by human action are now being done by computers. And new ways of applying computational approaches are constantly being innovated. And that itself introduces two problems. One is change. Any type of change fundamentally adjusts the security model. But two, the second part of the problem is that oftentimes people will think, oh, well, this is completely new. This is like the new age, state of the art, whatever, fill in the blank. We don't have to worry about those security
challenges the same way anymore. It's like, actually, you have to worry about them more because it's now a different thing. So that mindset really becomes quite a problem. So I'm not necessarily disagreeing with you fully, but I'm just modifying the way you stated it. Some things are getting tighter, but some things are actually getting worse. And actually both are happening at the same time. Ah, interesting. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, it's a real arms race. It's an arms race between the ethical
and the non-ethical hackers. And it's also an arms race between the ethical hackers and productivity. The developers who want to just get this beta version of this code out really quickly, and who cares if it has some security issue, we just need to get this result really quick. And so it seems like there's a sort of triangle there. So there's a lot of truth in what you just said. The conflict actually is less that developers don't care about security. I think any developer listening to this right now would probably dispute that because they're being told like either they already care about it or they're being told by their boss or their, you know, any member of the leadership in the company.
Like you have to care about this. The problem isn't whether they care or not. The problem is how are they going to do that? Because building and breaking are two fundamentally different things. So here's a way to think about it. I'm a big believer in using metaphors to try to explain what can be sometimes really complicated ideas. This one, I don't think is that complicated, but this idea that you think about building a skyscraper, right? There is a person, a type of general contractor who that's what they specialize in. They build high rises.
If you went to that contractor and you said, okay, now we need you to be the demolition expert. Can you demo a skyscraper? They'd be like, maybe. Yeah. I mean, I guess I know where the weakness is. I could probably, yeah. Yeah.
Okay. Let's do that. But would they know what they're doing relative to the person who spends every waking minute demoing buildings? Right. It's like, it's an impossible ask to think that just because they're related, that someone can be the expert in both. And that's really, that's what businesses are asking of developers. They're like, you have to build it and you also have to be the expert in how to break it. And that's just unreasonable. And that's impractical. And when push comes to shove and when the boss says to the developer, you have to build it. It has to be done by this time. It has to meet this quality standard. Oh, and it has to be secure.
When push comes to shove, what's going to get axed? The security part, because it's also not with the developer's area of expertise. So that sucks for a developer, right? Because that's really bad for a developer because they're being pushed into this difficult box of so much empathy for that situation that they're in. Once we realize that is the business problem that it is, then we can start to figure out how do we address it. Yeah, that totally makes sense. Yeah, I think, yeah, to continue your analogy, I think there's a whole bunch of really interesting bits there on how people demo buildings in real life and how they make it so the building implodes, it doesn't like fall on another building and kill a bunch of people or something.
And so people who build buildings wouldn't know anything about that. And yeah, and speaking from experience, I've built a lot of software and we had an issue, this is about a year ago, where we had a external facing website for a team. My team was working on an open source system that was published in the open source
really for brand awareness and advertising of our work and to contribute back to the research community. And we had an internal version. And to kind of cut the story short, one of the engineers accidentally allowed anybody to, um, to take over, to hijack our website. And, uh, um, and there was a team internally that actually is just focused on hijacking company websites. And so within, I want to say within maybe even less than an hour, I mean, it must've been automated. Basically they instantly hijacked our website and then,
and then they set up a meeting on our calendar where we could talk about how we totally got owned. And they explained a whole bunch of stuff to us that us researchers had never known before. But, um, but yeah, I mean, that team totally saved our bacon because, uh, we didn't, I would have been terrible if we had been hijacked by somebody else. Totally. Yeah. Well, I'm glad they reached out to you. They went through, it sounds like they went through responsible disclosure. Uh, there's maybe some questionable parts of what exactly they did. Um, but yeah, you're right. You want the good guy to find it, not the bad guy to find it.
Yeah, totally. So this is really interesting. So you're in DC and you're in college, right? And so you met this gentleman while you were in college and the two of you, yeah, can you bridge the gap from that to go to ISC? Did you start ISC right then and there or is there what's in the middle
there? No, there was actually a pretty significant gap there. And one of the things that I would highlight out of this is for anybody who's right now thinking about security as a career, but thinks, well, I don't know as much as all these other people, or I don't have enough, you know, the ship has already sailed. I'm already down whatever this engineering path is that I'm down. It's not too late. I didn't enter security until I was, I would have probably been at that point. I should know this, but I would have been probably my late twenties. So, you know, I'd been in, I'd had 10 ish years of a career already. And, uh, so I knew nothing by my late twenties. And then over And the time in between, I was essentially, I wasn't even in tech. I was chasing my entrepreneurial dreams, which was, I was looking for some mentorship. So I worked at a company for a little while that I was able to work directly under the CEO of this one company. And then I became the CEO myself of a tech company that was focused around water.
And then I met the guy who would become my business partner almost by chance. We knew a guy in common. I knew this guy from the NSA who went to the PhD program with my business partner. And this guy in common was like, you guys are in such different worlds, but you should meet. And so we did. And so in a sense, it was being open to whatever opportunities might present themselves. Because on paper, like, we shouldn't even have met each other. We were just like in such different worlds. And we knew pretty much right away because philosophically, we were very aligned. Um, and in a way, all those years, not in security at all, have helped me be able to be a better communicator about security. Because I came in to this profession so much later than most people. I mean, I'm surrounded by people who are like, Oh, yeah, I like ripped open a video game console when I was five. And I'm like, I didn't, what? I didn't even know what the principles of security were until I was like 29.
You know, like there's a huge difference between that. But because I was able to come from this other perspective that was like, explain that to me. I don't understand that. All of the assumptions that I should know anything, I was not troubled by them. And that's one of the things I think holds a lot of people back. They're like, oh, I have a degree in computer science. I should probably know this thing. So I'm not going to ask a question that might make it seem like I don't know what I'm talking about. I'm like, hey, guys, Ted here. Don't know what I'm talking about.
Quick question. And because of that, I was able to sort of like build this foundation of knowledge over a long period of time. And that was something I hope everyone listening to this can realize like, no one knows anything about anything. So just ask questions. No one's going to judge you. Like we all have imposter syndrome. We all think we're not smart enough. Just keep pushing and asking questions and you'll figure it out. Yeah, that's really, really good advice. Yeah, definitely. I think, you know, every job that I've ever had, I went through the imposter syndrome phase where basically I said, you know, I, you know, I kind of, you know, I got lucky in this interview or, you know, I interviewed at four places and I picked one job that's because, you know, I got lucky that one time. And, you know, or, you know,
I really oversold myself in the interview and now I don't know what I'm doing. This is completely common. You know, everybody goes through imposter syndrome every single time. Um, and, and so, you know, I think that, uh, um, the, the, the thing that, that, you know, over time I've learned is to, is it's, it's kind of like, uh, uh, I'm trying to remember what, what there's a program, but like the first step of, uh, I think it's like a alcoholics anonymous or something, but, but the first step of like a lot of these programs is like recognize, uh, you know, be able to see yourself from the outside as an outsider. And so, so I've learned that, you know, this, this, uh, you know, this imposter syndrome, uh, I've, I can kind of see it from the outside. And now when I start something new,
a new team or a new job or new, whatever I say, look, I'm going to go into this, you know, the dumbest person in the room on say, look, I'm going to go into this, you know, the dumbest person in the room on this subject, and I'm going to know I'm the dumbest person in the room, and everyone else is going to know that. And that's okay. That's totally fine. Because the company is not hiring you, or that person is not hiring you, you know, if you're a freelance developer, for what you can do in the first five minutes. You know, they're hiring you to do a task that's going to take months, maybe even years. And especially if you're doing things that require, you know, NSA clearance and these things. I mean, they have to have multiple year
horizon when they evaluate somebody. And so I think, you know, that you're always going to have that imposter syndrome, but recognizing it for what it is helps tremendously. Totally. I mean, I even think if for anyone who feels the imposter syndrome, which maybe we should define that real quick for anyone who doesn't familiar with this, the idea is people who feel like I'm not smart enough. I shouldn't be in this room. I shouldn't be in this job. There's other people smarter than me. That's called the imposter syndrome. And I think anyone who feels that way actually is probably one of the smarter people in the room because you recognize there's more to learn. There's always someone who's more of the expert at something. And the fact that someone's more of an expert than you doesn't make you stupid. It makes you on the path to becoming an expert yourself, or it makes you smart to realize that let me get the expertise of this
other person to help me solve this problem. And maybe I don't even ever want to become that expert. I don't want to become an expert on how to fix plumbing in my house. I don't want to do it. I am always going to have an expert plumber. I'm not going to watch YouTube videos to figure out how to replumb any part of my house. I'm going to hire somebody. And I think that's, there's strength in that and realizing like, okay, well, I'm going to choose my brainpower to focus on something else. Right. Yep.
Yep. Yeah, totally agree. So, um, so, you know, when, when a lot of people think about hacking, so we'll, we'll talk about hacking and then we'll talk about ethical hacking. When people think about hacking, I think there's two extremes. I think on one extreme, people think it's like, you know, CSI, you know, that, that meme where the person's like, I'm going to write a visual basic script to trace the hacker did to do, do, do done. You know, and now we know everything about them. And then there's the other extreme and where they feel like there really is no such thing as technical hacking.
It's all just phishing and sort of social engineering. Right. And so, you know, kind of where are things? How has that spectrum kind of changed over time? And what really is hacking at the end of the day? That's the question that we should answer first is what is hacking? Or another way we could ask it is what is a hacker? And here's how we have to think about that, is that most people actually think that a hacker is a malicious person, somehow associated with wrongdoing, evildoing, whatever. And that's actually not entirely true.
A hacker is a problem solver. A hacker is somebody who sees the way a system works and says, can it behave differently than it was intended to? That's not good or bad. That's just a way of thinking. That's a predisposition, I guess. The fork in the road comes when we think about motivation. So someone who wants to take a system and repurpose it or make it behave in ways that it wasn't intended to behave, and they want to do that to obtain some sort of personal benefit at someone else's expense. They want to harm an organization or some other malicious outcome. That's what would be an attacker, a malicious hacker. But the other side of the fork of the road
is people who come from my corner of the world, which are ethical hackers. And those are people who still want to find those same flaws in the way that the system works, but they want to do that so that they can advise on how to fix it. And both are professions. I mean, there is a very mature marketplace for malicious attackers out there, and there is a mature marketplace for ethical hackers. And so that's really what hacking is. And all the examples that you described, those all are hacking, you know, social engineering, where you try to trick somebody, or attacking via a technical method where you're actually manipulating a software system. Maybe the idea of trying to have some sort of like attribution or, you know, chain of custody of who is a person that did a thing, like that's a slightly different thing that might not be hacking. That's more post incident. But
these are all types of hacking because essentially they're like, how do I take a system, make it behave differently? A person is a system. I can give you a social engineering example that is a system, right? Like one time I wanted to get into a bar and there was a long line and there was a cover charge to get into the bar and I didn't want to do either of those. And so I recognized for what it was, right? It was a system. There was a system that says, you know, you're a patron, you go through this line, at the end of the line, you pay a cover and you go into the bar. That's how the system worked. But I also noticed there's another feature to this system, which is if you're a VIP, you can go in the VIP line, there's no wait, and you don't pay
cover. And so what did I do? I did what any hacker minded person would do. And they said, well, how do I make the system behave differently? I'm not VIP, but how can I make it so the system thinks that I am? And so I went through a whole series of sort of leading questions and specially crafted inputs, the way that I said things to the VIP hostess to get her to reveal to me through the way I asked questions, who was a group on the VIP list. And then I could just say, I'm with that group. And sure enough, that's exactly what I did. She was able to let me in the bar, didn't wait in line, didn't pay cover. I have a similar story to that.
That's amazing. I have a story where I was, yeah, I always fly coach pretty much. I mean, I've flown first class a few times because I had enough points. One time I flew business class for work, but I'm generally flying coach. There was a massive line at the check-in area. And this is before, I mean, now you would just check in on your phone. It's no big deal. This was before that.
And so there was no line for first class. And so my idea was that I would get in the first class line and I would upgrade to first class and just pay whatever it is because it was worth it. Otherwise, I was going to miss my flight. And that extra value made first class worth it. And so I did that. I got the first class line. I upgraded. It cost me out of me 200 bucks or something. And because of that, I didn't miss my flight. And the people who a couple of people heard what was happening because when I passed, you know, hundreds of people in the regular line, obviously that drew a lot of attention. And a couple of people heard what was happening because when I passed, you know, hundreds of people in the regular line, obviously that drew a lot of attention and a couple of people were
listening and they saw what I did and they got really upset. And, uh, um, you know, I think maybe that's, that's part of hacking is, is, is when you do, when you abuse a system, you instantly sort of draw the ire of everyone around you. But, was, I think, though, one of the few times I could think of my life where, yeah, I kind of purposely kind of took advantage of a bit of a gray area. I wasn't first class yet, but I was about to be. And so that got me on the flight. And so, yeah, those moments are a little bit magical. Like it's, it is kind of, you know, a weird feeling, but, you know, when you kind of use a system in a different way, there's a certain, you know, feeling that you get, I can't really, you know, you'd probably describe it way better than I do, but there's a certain feeling you get like, like, yeah, like I managed to pull this off, you know?
Absolutely. There's, there's such an interesting element to, I love that story, by the way. Um, I would probably do that all the time. Like if you knew that, like, Hey, just go in this line, pay a little bit more, and then your life is, yes. Transfer money for time anywhere that you can. I'm all about that. But there's a really interesting element to the story that you just described. And it is the reaction of, I don't mean this in a diminutive way, but the reaction of the regular people.
Because we're talking about what's the definition of hacking. Well, there's people who, most people, when they see a system, they say, how does the system work? And I'm going to comply with the rules of the system. And then there are hackers and hackers say, how does the system work? And I am going to either modify the system or abuse the system within the rules or change the rules. And the reaction that you saw was the inherently human feeling we have about fairness of those people who are like, hey, I followed the rules, and I didn't get the benefit. But most people are in that mode. Most people are, let's follow the rules. And that's why hackers, both of the good variety and the bad variety, are good at what they do and are necessary in, we're talking about social engineering right now, but in all aspects of building anything, because the average person
doesn't look at things that way. Those people who got mad at you for doing what you did, why were they mad? Because they didn't get the benefit. But what did they not do? They did not look at that system and say, how do I make it behave differently? It's a special kind of mindset that's required to do that. And that's why people like us have a profession actually, you know, get hired by companies to help them solve problems like these. And it's a really, really, really important distinction. Yeah, that makes sense. So, so would you say the majority of, let's say breaches, for lack of a better word, are from social engineering nowadays? Or, you know, what's that mixture like? I wouldn't be able to answer that definitively i'm
sure there's endless statistics out there that could answer that question without an a shadow of a doubt in their mind in any direction um because the truth is that at some point we don't actually know everything about every attack in fact we probably know very little about most attacks. But I do believe, not even believe, this is a fundamental truth, is that there is a human element to any attack. Now, I spend my energy, our entire organization, our company, we spend our energy really focused on how do we prevent software systems from being breached? That's really the main thrust. And then by extension, networks, computer networks and things like that. We don't focus as much on social engineering, but even I, as a person who focuses on software, recognize that the human is actually at the heart of all of these problems. So even if it's
not that someone called up engineer Jane and said, Hey, engineer Jane, I'm gonna send you something. Will you click it? Even if that's not what happened, engineer Jane might've built something and let's not make it Jane's fault. Engineer Joe, Engineer Joe and Jane together. But they're humans and they didn't realize that an attacker might abuse functionality that they were building in a certain way. And that is why that particular software system got breached. So anyone who's out there saying that, you know, 85% of breaches are the result of social engineering. It's like, maybe. I mean, sure, there's data that might show that, but I don't know if that data sets complete. Yeah, that totally makes sense. I mean, this is such a, or maybe just the circles I run, this is such a cliche, but other people,
people out there might have not heard this. Patrick, I'm sure you've heard this. The World War II story about the planes that came back with bullet holes. So, uh, I'll just recap this for people who've never heard this story. Um, you know, the, in world war two, they're sending out planes. Some of the planes were getting shot down. Some of them were getting, uh, uh, I guess, wounded or, or damaged and then come back. And then some of them were coming back, you know, totally undamaged. And so they were looking at the damaged ones and saying, Oh, you know, they're getting shot a lot in this spot and that spot let's put some more armor so that they don't come back with a big hole in them in this spot and uh it actually didn't didn't help at all
um or very little it definitely didn't improve the kill rate and and the reason is because the ones that were downed were not coming back so So it's like if your plane is coming back, that's actually a good thing. And so maybe those spots are actually fine and you want to reinforce all the spots that you don't have any bullet holes in. And so it's similar here where it could be such that the breaches that occur from social engineering just end up being more public. And so you're just not seeing the distribution accurately. And so to your point, it could really be anything. But I guess the high level bit we can take away from this is that they're both still used extensively. So there's still a lot of social engineering. I actually just got a text message saying, hey, I need some information, blah, blah, blah, signed. And it's the CEO of my company. And my first reaction is
嗯，或者说非常少，它绝对没有提高击落率，原因在于被击落的飞机根本没有回来。所以这就好比，如果你的飞机能飞回来，其实是一件好事。所以也许那些弹痕所在的位置其实没问题，你真正需要加固的，反而是那些没有任何弹痕的地方。这里的情况也很类似，通过社会工程学造成的安全漏洞，最终往往会闹得人尽皆知。因此，你只是没有准确地看到分布情况。所以正如你所说，这真的可能是什么情况都有。不过我想我们可以从中得出的一个宏观结论是，这两种手段至今仍被广泛使用。所以仍然有大量的社会工程学攻击。我其实刚刚才收到一条短信，说“嘿，我需要一些信息，巴拉巴拉”，落款署名竟然是我公司的CEO。而我的第一反应是
like, who signs a text message? And my second reaction is like, why does the CEO, you know, like, like, they're like, why would he ever text me? And then sure enough, this is like, this got sent to like tons of people. So that's definitely happening all the time. But to your point, you know, the software side, I'm sure is happening just as often or is happening in large numbers. And it's something that folks should definitely be aware of. Absolutely.
像，谁会给短信签名啊？我的第二个反应是，为什么CEO会，你知道的，就是，他怎么可能会给我发短信？然后果真如此，这条短信发给了成千上万的人。所以这种事绝对一直在发生。但正如你所说，软件层面的攻击，我敢肯定也同样在发生，或者说正以极大的规模发生着。这是大家绝对应该意识到的一点。绝对是的。
Yeah. something that folks should definitely be aware of absolutely yeah yeah so um is is is hacking kind of like magic where you know kind of once you tell someone the secret is not useful anymore like like what are the parallels there wow first of all i love the phrasing of that question uh a lot of people do think it's like magic. They think we have this magic wand. We get contacted almost every day by someone who's like, oh, can you? So what I do is what we do, we help companies like who are building software and there's like big projects, but I get contacted all the time by individuals who are like, my ex hacked my phone and is looking at my email. And I'm like, what am I going to do with that? They're like, well, you have a magic wand, right? So people always think that ethical hackers, we have this magic wand. So I love the way you phrased the question. And the nuance to your question is that once someone knows how a magic trick works, it loses, it's not as enchanting. And that is in fact, not the case
是的，这是大家绝对应该意识到的一点，绝对是的，对，对。所以，嗯，黑客攻击有点像变魔术吗？就是说，一旦你把秘密告诉了别人，它就不再有用了？这其中有什么相似之处吗？哇，首先，我太喜欢你这个问题的措辞了。很多人确实觉得它就像魔术。他们认为我们手里有什么魔术棒。几乎每天都有人联系我们，说：“哦，你能……？”我的工作，我们做的工作是帮助那些正在构建软件、有大项目的公司，但我经常接到个人的电话，说：“我的前任黑客入侵了我的手机，正在查看我的电子邮件。”我就想：“我能拿这个怎么办？”他们会说：“嗯，你手里有魔术棒，对吧？”所以人们总觉得道德黑客手里有这种魔术棒。所以我很喜欢你提出这个问题的方式。而你这个问题背后的微妙之处在于，一旦有人知道了魔术是怎么变的，它就会失去魅力，不再那么迷人了。而这事实上并不是
with ethical hacking. It's not like, well, once we reveal the method, all of a sudden, somehow it's no longer effective. In fact, the methods have been long established for a very, very long time. And that was one of the things that I was thinking about a lot when I was writing my book is if you're going to write a book that has to do with technology and it's going to take, you know, I wrote my book actually very fast for writing a book. It was about 17 months from when I started it until it was published. That's like crazy fast. Most people take like 10 years to write a book or five. But even in my case, where it's like as fast as it can be, the question is, well, how will that be useful to people in
道德黑客所面临的情况。并不是说，一旦我们揭示了某种方法，它突然之间就变得不再有效了。事实上，这些方法早在很久很久以前就已经确立了。这也是我在写书时经常思考的问题之一：如果你要写一本与技术相关的书，而且这本书需要——其实我写书的速度非常快，从动笔到出版大约花了17个月。这简直快得离谱。大多数人写一本书要花10年或5年。但即使在我这种以最快速度完成的情况下，问题依然是：在
three, five, 10, 20 years? Will it be useful? And when technology changes that fast, that's a valid, valid question. And so for that reason, I really focused on, well, what are some of the things that are either timeless or are going to be highly resistant to change in time? And that's the principles of security. These principles that we have to think about today are pretty much the same principles as they were 10, 20, 30 years ago in tech. And you can even see these same principles in ancient books about war. Like for example, Sun Tzu wrote the art of war and many of the principles, the art about war, like, for example, Sun Tzu wrote The Art of War, and many of the principles in The Art of War, many of the principles in Machiavelli's The Prince, these books are crazy old, and these principles apply to how we defend software systems today. You have to think about it differently, obviously, than an emperor ruling a kingdom. And it's a slightly different application of the ideas, but the ideas are the same.
三年、五年、十年、二十年后，这对人们还有用吗？它会有用吗？当技术变化如此之快时，这是一个非常现实、非常切合实际的问题。因此，出于这个原因，我真正关注的是，有哪些东西是永恒的，或者在时间面前具有极强的抗变能力的？那就是安全原则。今天我们必须考虑的这些原则，与科技界10年、20年、30年前的原则几乎一模一样。你甚至可以在古代关于战争的书籍中看到这些相同的原则。比如，孙武写了《孙子兵法》，其中的许多原则——关于战争的艺术，比如，孙武写了《孙子兵法》，《孙子兵法》中的许多原则，以及马基雅维利《君主论》中的许多原则——这些书古老得离谱，但这些原则同样适用于我们今天防御软件系统的方式。显然，你必须用不同于皇帝统治王国的方式去思考它。这些理念的应用方式略有不同，但理念本身是相同的。
So when you read a book like the one that I wrote, which it's called Hackable, when you read a book like this and you see it lays out exactly like, here's how an ethical hacker goes through the process. Here's what you're looking for. Here's why it matters. Here's why most companies are stumbling
所以，当你读一本像我写的那样名为《可被黑客攻击》（Hackable）的书时，当你读到这样一本书，看到它清晰地列出：“道德黑客的整个流程是这样的。这就是你在寻找的东西。这就是它重要的原因。这就是为什么大多数公司在
when they like skip this part. I point it all out, the whole thing. It's not going to change the way the attackers attack. They're still going to attack. They're going to evolve and adapt. But now that it's completely open kimono, and I'm not the first person to have described the ideas, it's not like the magic trick where now it's like oh well the magic trick doesn't work anymore it still works because these principles are pretty timeless or at least time resistant that makes sense i remember um i somehow oh when i was taking systems engineering um that gentleman, the professor, he also taught this cyber forensics course, which I didn't take that course, but it was interesting. He would tell stories about it.
跳过这一部分时会跌跟头。”我都一一指出来了，全部内容。这不会改变攻击者攻击的方式。他们依然会发起攻击。他们会不断演进和适应。但既然现在一切都彻底公开了——而且我并不是第一个描述这些理念的人——它并不像魔术那样，现在大家会觉得“哦，这个魔术不管用了”。它依然管用，因为这些原则相当永恒，或者至少能够经受时间的考验。这说得通。我记得，嗯，我不知怎么的——当我在读系统工程学时，那位教授也教过网络取证这门课，虽然我没有选修那门课，但它非常有趣。他会讲一些关于这方面的故事。
And the one story that really resonated with me was he said, so at some point, people were kind of challenging him and saying, well, I could do this and I could use this VPN and I can use, and I'm going to say a bunch of things I don't know a lot about, but I can use like this onion router and I can use that. And at some point he kind of stopped and he said, here's the thing, you could do all of these things, but it's just another sort of dimension, right? It's like, it's like if you commit a crime, you know, now you, you know, have to deal with making sure that there's no evidence in the physical world and you have to deal with making sure there's no evidence in the digital world and you have to be experts on both of those and, and, um, um, you know, and, and, and all the different dimensions that, that, you know,
真正引起我共鸣的一个故事是，他说，在某个时候，人们开始质疑他，说：“嗯，我可以这样做，我可以使用这个VPN，我可以使用……我接下来要说一堆我其实不太了解的东西，但我可以使用洋葱路由器（onion router）之类的东西，我可以使用那个。”然后他在某个时刻停了下来，说：“情况是这样的，你可以做所有这些事情，但这只是另一个维度，对吧？这就好比，如果你犯罪了，现在你必须处理好确保物理世界中没有任何证据，你还必须确保数字世界中没有任何证据，你必须成为这两方面的专家，而且，嗯，嗯，你知道的，还有你能在
that you can, you can think of within those two universes two universes he's like and so this is an area where someone might slip up they might have really good uh way to some evil person might have really good way to cover their tracks um but not digitally and so that that kind of really resonated with me it's like it's like um um you know there's so many different vectors here and um and so even if you might learn kind of uh kind of like one magic trick it doesn't mean you know every magic trick right doesn't mean that you know every and and people are constantly coming up with new uh there's that Penn and Teller show on on uh um I don't know on like where it's syndicated but you can see it on YouTube where people kind of invent new tricks and share it with Penn and Teller. And so to your point, what really stays constant is the philosophy and the principles.
这两个宇宙中想到的所有不同维度。”他说：“所以，这是一个人们可能会失手的地方。某个邪恶的人可能有一套非常好的方法来掩盖自己的行踪，但在数字层面上却没有做好。”所以这一点真的引起了我的共鸣。这就好比，嗯，嗯，你知道的，这里有太多不同的载体了，而且，嗯，所以即使你可能只学会了某种——类似于某一个魔术，并不意味着你知道所有的魔术，对吧？并不意味着你知道每一个魔术，而且人们总是在不断想出新的……YouTube上不是有个潘恩和铁勒（Penn and Teller）的节目吗，我不知道它是在哪个台联合播出的，但你可以在YouTube上看到人们发明新魔术并与潘恩和铁勒分享。所以正如你所说，真正保持不变的是哲学和原则。
But then beyond that, there's, there's always more to learn and there's always sort of this adaptive, this complex adaptive system that's, that's being played out. And so, and so just knowing if you were to, even if you were to become an expert on all the different, um, you know, uh, um, like exploits, it doesn't mean that it doesn't put you, uh, um, Ted out of a job. Right. Yep. Things will continue to evolve and adapt. And, uh, I mean, let's be honest. If, if I could put myself out of a job, that would be a life's achievement. But I just don't think that it would ever be ever be possible. Yeah, you know, it actually fascinates me and it's something I just haven't ever taken the time to study.
但在那之外，总是有更多的东西要学，总是有这种适应性的、复杂的适应系统在运行。所以，即使你成为了解所有不同……你知道的……漏洞的专家，这并不意味着它会让你——嗯——失业。对的。事情将继续演进和适应。而且，说实话，如果我能让自己失业，那将是人生的最高成就。但我只是觉得这永远、永远都不可能发生。是的，你知道的，这其实让我很着迷，而且我从来没有花时间去研究它。
But just how things like trust, you know, really worked, especially in the past. Yeah, I was, I was, my, my son is now getting older. And so I'm starting to show him the, the amazing glory of video games. And so I was showing him, I don't remember which game it was. But anyway, so I walked up to the king and he gave me a quest and, you know, showing this to my son. And it just kind of crossed my mind that like, you know, I'm carrying this sword and I could decapitate all these different things and the king just lets me walk right up to him, you know? And so it made me think like, I wonder in the medieval world how that actually worked.
但诸如信任之类的事情是如何真正发挥作用的，尤其是在过去。是的，我当时……我的儿子现在长大了。所以我开始向他展示电子游戏的无上荣光。所以我正在给他看——我不记得是哪个游戏了。总之，我走到国王面前，他给了我一个任务，你知道的，我把这个展示给我的儿子。我脑子里突然闪过一个念头：我带着这把剑，我可以把各种东西斩首，而国王却让我大摇大摆地走到他面前，你知道吗？这让我不禁思考：我很好奇在中世纪的世界里，这到底是怎么运作的呢？
You know, like how did people with weapons get close to the king and there's sort of a trust there and how do you watch the watchmen and all of that. And so to your point, I mean, these are just timeless parts of human nature that will just never go away. and you know if we take the politics out of it which unfortunately is in this day and age is pretty hard to do now but if we just look at like purely the idea of the scientific control of uh you know a pandemic and you think about like why why did we have masks and social distancing and minimizing um you know gatherings and closed businesses. And like, why did we do all of these things?
你知道的，身怀武器的人是怎么靠近国王的？这其中存在某种信任，你又该如何监督监督者呢？诸如此类。所以正如你所说，这些只是人类天性中永恒的一部分，永远不会消失。如果我们撇开政治不谈——虽然在这个时代这相当困难——但如果我们纯粹从科学控制……你知道的……大流行的角度来看，你会想：为什么我们要戴口罩、保持社交距离、尽量减少……你知道的……集会和关闭企业？
Because these were all exercises in defense in depth. Like defense in depth is a security principle that essentially says, let's add layers of things to make it so that the bad outcome we wanna make sure we avoid is less likely to happen. And so that's why you do masks and social distancing and washing hands and like all these things. Because none of them, no single approach is wholly effective. And that's the same with, you know, building a system, the security mechanisms
我们为什么要做好所有这些事情？因为这些都是纵深防御（defense in depth）的实践。纵深防御是一种安全原则，其核心意思是：让我们增加多层防护，以降低我们极力想要避免的糟糕结果发生的可能性。这就是为什么我们要戴口罩、保持社交距离、勤洗手以及做所有这些事情的原因。因为没有任何一种单一的方法是完全有效的。这与构建系统以及系统中的
in a system. So kings, medieval times wonderful metaphor. When we think about the King, actually, I talk about castles a lot as a security metaphor. And you look at something like the tower of London, you know, and that used to protect the crown jewels. It doesn't anymore, but that literally used to protect the crown jewels. And if you wanted to get to the crown jewels, you had to get across the moat with the alligators in it you had to somehow like now scale the walls that had the guys pouring the hot oil down on you and the archers up on the turrets and once you get over the wall then you have to deal with the king's guard and you're now fighting them in hand-to-hand combat and then you have to get
安全机制是一样的。所以，国王，中世纪，这是一个绝妙的比喻。当我们想到国王时，事实上，我经常把城堡作为安全的比喻。你看一下伦敦塔之类的地方，你知道的，它过去常常用来保护王冠上的珠宝。现在不用了，但它过去确实是用来保护王冠上的珠宝的。如果你想拿到王冠上的珠宝，你必须穿过里面有短吻鳄的护城河，你必须设法爬上那些有人往下泼热油的城墙，还有塔楼上的弓箭手；一旦你翻过了城墙，你还得对付国王的卫兵，与他们进行近身肉搏战，然后你还得突破
through all these you know perimeter uh concentric perimeter walls in the castle and if you can eventually get through all that then maybe you can get to the king and then what now you have to get out you have to like do the whole thing in reverse yeah that's such a good metaphor for this really important principle defense in depth and so you were obviously talking about a video game they simplified it for like yeah you could walk up to the king holding a sword because a video game absolutely not an average person would not walk up to the king with a sword in medieval times right yeah unless they uh unless they got in through all those circles of trust right so that that that sort of closes the whole loop on the social engineering part right like somebody's
城堡里所有这些……你知道的……周界……同心圆周界墙。如果你最终能突破这一切，也许你就能见到国王了。然后呢？现在你得逃出去，你必须把整个过程反过来做一遍。是的，对于这个极其重要的原则——纵深防御来说，这是一个多么好的比喻啊。所以你显然是在谈论一个电子游戏，他们为了游戏效果将其简化了，比如，是的，你可以拿着剑走到国王面前，因为那是电子游戏。而在中世纪，一个普通人绝对不可能拿着剑走向国王，对吧？是的，除非他们通过了所有那些信任的圈子，对吧？所以这基本上把关于社会工程学的部分画上了一个完整的句号，对吧？就像有人
next to the king with a sword and so and so there's the sort of physical layers you know of getting to the crown jewels but then there's also all of these social layers and if you could i mean if this person was willing to spend the time and energy and they they had that evil in their heart or whatever like they they could eventually get to the point where they're right next to the king with the sword um um and and so that's that's a whole another uh aspect of it so someone um um someone said something interesting the a while back about basically uh the you know that that the people who are sort of most really interested and obsessed and focused on something um that that on average more of them are good people or i i'm trying to like you know mincing words here but but uh but yeah it's this
拿着剑站在国王旁边一样。因此，除了接近王冠珠宝的物理层之外，还有所有这些社会层。如果这个人愿意花时间和精力，并且他们心里怀有那种恶意之类的，他们最终就能走到手持长剑紧挨着国王的位置，嗯，嗯，所以这也是完全不同的另一个方面。所以有人……嗯……不久前说过一件有趣的事情，大意是……你知道的，那些真正对某事最感兴趣、着迷并专注于某事的人……平均而言，他们当中更多的是好人，或者说我在字斟句酌，不过……但是……是的，就是这种
idea that like you know so many people who will go through all that training to be the king's right hand person the king's protectorate or something, that at some point the odds of that person being evil just becomes so incredibly low that it passes some bar. You say, okay, now this person gets to be right next to the king with the sword, or this person gets to be in the secret service to make it more modern. And so that's the social engineering moat and alligators and boiling cauldron and all of that. And, and so I think, uh, uh, you know, building that trust over time is, is, is equally important. Yeah. I think a great metaphor for how do you, how do you deal with that? Right. It's not even a metaphor. It's just real life is you look at something like the movie The Departed.
观点：许多经历所有那些训练成为国王左右手、国王保护者之类角色的人，在某种程度上，这个人是坏人的概率变得如此之低，以至于它通过了某种标准。你会说：“好吧，现在这个人可以拿着剑紧挨着国王了”，或者“这个人可以进入特勤局了”（用现代的话来说）。这就是社会工程学的护城河、短吻鳄、沸腾的大锅以及所有这一切。所以我觉得，嗯，嗯，你知道的，随着时间的推移建立这种信任，同样重要。是的。我认为这是一个极好的比喻，说明了你该如何处理这种情况，对吧？这甚至都不是一个比喻。这就是现实生活。你看一下像《无间道》（The Departed）这样的电影。
I'm originally from the Boston area, so I'm very partial to all things set in or about Boston, including gangster movies, for whatever reason. Nice. But so this movie, I'm going to maybe include some spoilers, but it's like 20 years old. So if you haven't seen it yet- You can spoil it, go for it. Yeah, that's kind of on you.
我原本是波士顿人，所以我对所有以波士顿为背景或与波士顿有关的事物都非常偏爱，包括黑帮电影，不管出于什么原因。太棒了。但这部电影——我可能会剧透一些内容，但它已经上映快20年了。所以如果你还没看过的话……你可以剧透，尽管剧透吧。是的，那只能怪你自己了。
But you've got one of the main characters is an FBI agent and he goes to go undercover to try to get close to the kingpin, this guy, Whitey Bulger. And it really chronicles what it was like for that guy trying to do this, right? Because how do you earn the trust of a gangster? You have to do stuff that's directly opposed to your profession as a investigative police officer. Like, literally, you have to kill people. You have to rob people. You have to beat people up. And if you don't do those things, you fail the test and you'll probably die because the gangster is like, oh, this guy's not trustworthy according to gangster code. And then it talks about how it like, you know, as you watch the movie, how it
但片中有一个主要角色是一名联邦特工，他去卧底，试图接近黑帮老大怀蒂·巴尔格（Whitey Bulger）。它真实记录了这个人试图做到这一点的过程，对吧？因为你如何赢得一个黑帮分子的信任？你必须做一些直接违背你作为调查警官的职业道德的事情。比如，你真的必须杀人。你必须抢劫。你必须殴打别人。如果你不做这些事情，你就会通不过测试，而且你可能会死，因为黑帮会觉得：“哦，按照黑帮的法典，这家伙不值得信任。”然后电影探讨了，随着你观看电影，它如何
morphs this individual. And it's like, is he maybe starting to become bad himself now? And you don't necessarily know. And it's, I guess it's supporting your point that it's like, at some point, we have to trust people, we have to trust systems. And so we have to have a criteria by which we assign trust. And it shouldn't, we we assign trust. And we should assume hostility. We should be like that gangster who's like, hey, I need to test everyone who's around me just so they can be around me. Otherwise, how do I know? And then eventually they go through enough tests that you can trust them or you cannot trust them. And unfortunately, we do have to cross that barrier at some point, being able to trust. And this idea of trust is one of the big things that I actually argue about
改变了这个个体。就像是，他现在自己是不是也开始变坏了？而你并不一定知道。我想这支持了你的观点：在某个时刻，我们必须信任人，我们必须信任系统。因此我们必须有一套赋予信任的标准。而且它不应该……我们赋予信任。并且我们应该假设存在敌意。我们应该像那个黑帮分子一样：“嘿，我需要测试我周围的每个人，只有这样他们才能待在我身边。否则我怎么知道？”然后最终他们通过了足够的测试，你就可以信任他们，或者不能信任他们。不幸的是，在某个时刻，我们确实必须跨越信任这一关。而这种“信任”的概念是我在书中实际辩论的重大问题之一，
in my book, which is that security isn't actually just about securing something. It's about being able to earn trust, right? You need to be able to secure a system and you need to be able to prove it. And those are two different things. And One of the big failures that exists across industries, across geographic locations, across maturity of both individuals and security programs is that we oftentimes think that we can just tell somebody that something's secure. We think that we can prove it without actually securing it. And that doesn't work. That's like the person who's, I don't know, the Olympics are going on right now, right? It's like the person who's like, I'm the fastest speed skater. I should be on the team. And they're like, okay, well go in this race. And if you win the
那就是：安全实际上并不仅仅是关于确保某事物的安全。它是关于能够赢得信任，对吧？你需要能够确保一个系统的安全，并且你需要能够证明这一点。这是两码事。而在各个行业、各个地理位置、以及个人和安全项目的成熟度之间，存在着一个巨大的失败，那就是我们经常认为我们可以直接告诉别人某事是安全的。我们认为我们可以在不实际确保其安全的情况下证明它。而这是行不通的。这就好比那个人——我不知道，奥运会现在正在进行，对吧？——这就好比一个人说：“我是速度最快的速滑运动员。我应该进入国家队。”然后人们说：“好吧，去参加这场比赛。如果你赢得这场
race, you'll qualify for the team. And they're like, no, no, no, no. I'm the fastest. Just trust me. Yeah, right. That's the way a lot of people talk about security. They'll say things all the time. Pick a website, right? They'll go to it and they'll be like, fast, reliable, and secure. And you're like, I can determine if it's fast. I can determine if it's reliable.
比赛，你就有资格入选国家队。”而他们却说：“不，不，不，不。我是最快的。相信我。”是的，对吧。这就是许多人谈论安全的方式。他们总是会说这样的话。随便挑一个网站，对吧？他们会访问它，然后说：“快速、可靠且安全。”而你会说：“我可以确定它是否快速。我可以确定它是否可靠。
But only someone with security expertise can determine if this is actually secure. Yeah, that makes sense. Yeah, that's really interesting. The analogy with the movie, you know, I feel like, you know, because one could argue that it's hopeless, right? That there's no way of guaranteeing, and I'll go back to the medieval times because i feel like uh talking about modern times is uh it makes me nervous but but but there's nobody who can guarantee that the king's you know right hand person isn't going to kill you can't guarantee but to your point like maybe that king's right hand person has to do so many things you you know, in service of the king that, and get so intimate with the king and his family and the whole thing that at that point, even if he came in with the intention of, you know, killing the king, he would have been like brainwashed with all of these experiences
但只有具备安全专业知识的人才能确定它是否真的安全。”是的，这说得通。是的，这真的很有趣。与电影的类比，你知道的，我觉得——因为有人可能会争辩说这是无望的，对吧？没有任何方法可以保证……我会回到中世纪，因为我觉得谈论现代让我感到紧张——但是没有人能保证国王的左右手不会杀了你。你无法保证。但正如你所说，也许国王的左右手必须为了国王做如此多的事情，你知道的，并且与国王及其家人变得如此亲密，经历了整个过程，以至于到了那个时候，即使他带着刺杀国王的意图而来，他也会被所有这些经历洗脑，
that would have eventually defined his life and then he wouldn't do it. So I think, I think, yeah, maybe you could make the claim that it is then possible to create, you know, such a comprehensive set of hoops that even the most like untrustworthy or mal like intended person goes through that trial and comes out the other end trustworthy. That's kind of an interesting thing to think about. Yeah. I mean, I guess there's two ways that you'd get that insider. This is what we're talking about right now, right? The insider threat. One would be, yeah, someone joins the organization with the express intent to earn trust in order to harm the organization. But in other ways, they could be recruited. And so in the case of someone who's close to a high ranking head of state or whatever, how do you kill a king? Maybe there's a weakness
这些经历最终会定义他的人生，然后他就不会这么做了。所以我想，是的，也许你可以断言，创造一套如此包罗万象的关卡是可能的，以至于即使是最不可信或心怀恶意的人经历了这场考验，在另一头出来时也会变得值得信赖。这真是一个有趣的思考角度。是的。我的意思是，我想获取这种内部人员有两种途径。这就是我们现在正在讨论的，对吧？内部威胁。一种是，是的，某人带着明确的意图加入组织，以赢得信任，进而对组织造成伤害。但另一种方式是，他们可能会被招募。因此，对于那些接近高级国家元首之类的人来说，你如何杀死一个国王？也许
of that person who's in the guard, or maybe they, I don't know what their weakness is, but whatever the weakness is, an enemy can take advantage of that. And whatever the situation is, these are the things that, this is why every organization, irrespective of time, we're talking about medieval times, let's talk about modern times, like everywhere in between. This is why we really need someone, or not even someone like a team who is constantly thinking those more malicious thoughts, but for good. I mean, that's, again, this is why my whole profession exists is because most people don't think this way. It's a very uncomfortable way to see the world. It's like, I forget in the matrix, which pill it is that you take that all of a sudden you unplug from the matrix,
那个卫兵身上有某种弱点，或者也许他们……我不知道他们的弱点是什么，但无论弱点是什么，敌人都可以利用这一点。无论情况如何，这些都是原因——这就是为什么每个组织，无论时代如何（我们讨论过中世纪，让我们谈谈现代，以及介于两者之间的所有地方），这就是为什么我们真正需要某个人，甚至不仅仅是某个人，而是一个不断思考那些更具恶意的想法但出发点却是为了善良的团队。我的意思是，这也是为什么我的整个行业能够存在，因为大多数人不会这样思考。这是一种非常不舒服的世界观。这就像——我忘了在《黑客帝国》（The Matrix）里，你吃的是哪颗药丸就能突然从母体中拔掉插头，
but it's like taking that pill. Yeah. The red pill, you unplug the blue pill, you stay in the matrix, I think. Yeah. So it's like you take the red pill, you're unplugged and now you're like, well, this is way worse you stay in the matrix, I think. Yeah. So it's like you take the red pill, you're unplugged. And now you're like, well, this is way worse than being in the matrix was. Like now I see it's so uncomfortable. I see the ugliness of the world. But just like the main characters in that movie, we need people to see the ugliness in the world in order to improve the world.
但这就像吃了那颗药丸。是的。红色的药丸，你拔掉插头；蓝色的药丸，你留在母体里，我想。是的。所以这就好比你吃了红色药丸，你被拔掉了插头。现在你会觉得：“嗯，这比待在母体里糟糕多了。现在我看到了，这太让人不舒服了。我看到了世界的丑陋。”但就像那部电影中的主角一样，我们需要有人看到世界丑陋的一面，以便改善这个世界。
And like those of us who come from the ethical hacking world, it's like, we see everything this way. Like I told the story about the bar or whatever, but it's like literally every situation in my life, I look at it in that more malicious, like, well, how would you defeat this? And that's not for everybody to think that way. That's, that's probably not healthy. In fact, for everybody to think that way. But that's why we have to have someone or someone's, plural, thinking that way. Because going back to the medieval king metaphor, if someone's not analyzing who's close to the king and what are the weaknesses that person might have, a bad apple might get close. Yeah, totally. So when a company approaches you and says, Ted, we want you and ISE to help us out, let's say they haven't had a breach yet because that's probably a totally different situation. But let's say they just want you to come in and help to secure their company. What do you do? What is day one like? How does that go down?
就像我们这些出身于道德黑客世界的人一样，我们以这种方式看待一切。就像我讲的那个关于酒吧的故事之类的，但我生活中的每一个情境，我都是从更具恶意的角度去看待的，比如：“你会如何攻破这个？”并不是每个人都需要这样思考。那样思考可能并不健康，事实上，如果所有人都那样思考的话。但这就是为什么我们必须有某个人或某些人（复数）这样思考。因为回到中世纪国王的比喻，如果没有人在分析谁接近了国王以及这个人可能有什么弱点，坏蛋就可能会靠近。是的，完全如此。所以，当一家公司找到你并说：“泰德，我们希望你和ISE（公司名）来帮我们一把”，假设他们还没有遭到泄露，因为这可能是一个完全不同的情况。但假设他们只是想让你进来帮忙确保他们公司的安全。你会怎么做？第一天是怎样的？事情是怎么展开的？
Well, it depends on the scope of the project and what they're trying to do. But let's say someone who's building a software system and their motivations may be several. They might themselves realize, hey, we know we need this to be secure. Or we may realize we're building something that is going to be very, very valuable to attackers. So we should get out ahead of this. But most likely, the reason that they want to do this, or they're being asked to do it is a customer of theirs is asking them to do it. Or a regulator in an industry they are building the system for is saying, hey, you got to prove it in some way. And so usually what happens is that we get
嗯，这取决于项目的范围以及他们试图做什么。但假设有人在构建一个软件系统，他们的动机可能有很多。他们自己可能意识到：“嘿，我们知道我们需要确保这东西的安全。”或者我们可能意识到，我们正在构建的东西对攻击者来说将是非常非常有价值的。所以我们应该防患于未然。但最有可能的是，他们想要这样做或被要求这样做的原因是他们的某个客户正在要求他们这样做。或者他们为其构建系统的行业监管机构说：“嘿，你必须以某种方式证明这一点。”所以通常发生的情况是，我们
to the heart of what do they want to achieve? Why do they want to achieve that? Usually what they're asking for winds up being a little bit different than what they actually need. Most people think of security as a box to check or a cost to minimize. How do we do this the least expensive way that will satisfy my customer? That's the way a lot of people think about it. But the smart companies are the ones who say, well, if one customer is asking for this, I bet a bunch of my others are too.
会切入他们的核心诉求：他们想实现什么？他们为什么要实现这个？通常他们所要求的事情，最终往往与他们实际需要的有些许不同。大多数人认为安全只是一个需要勾选的框，或者是一项需要最小化的成本。我们如何以最便宜的方式做到这一点，从而让我的客户满意？很多人的想法都是这样的。但聪明的公司会说：“嗯，如果有一个客户在要求这个，我敢打赌我的其他客户也一样。”
So why don't I not do the minimum? Why don't I capture the competitive advantage that this is and do it the right way and be able to differentiate from everyone else who's going to see what's the lowest bar that I can do right now. That's huge. It's kind of like, yeah, the analogy is kind of like, you know, the robber in the neighborhood will try and rob the easiest target. Most people don't rob every house in the neighborhood or even half the houses. They're going to find like the one or two houses that they can rob.
所以为什么我只做最低标准呢？为什么不抓住这个竞争优势，用正确的方式去做，从而把自己和那些只想着‘我现在能做的最低标准是什么’的所有其他人区分开来呢？这太重要了。这就好比——是的，这个类比有点像，你知道的，社区里的强盗会试图抢劫最容易下手的目标。大多数人不会抢劫社区里的每一栋房子，甚至连一半的房子都不会。他们会找到那一两栋可以抢劫的房子。
And so you just need to be better than them. Or I guess the other analogy is like, you know, if there's a lion chasing you, you just have to be the second slowest runner, you know? Well, here's maybe, okay. I like the combination of homes and lions. Let's, let's use a metaphor of homes in South Africa. Okay. So the home security, South Africa is significant because there's, you know, home robberies are like a really big problem there. And so really what we're talking about is the person who sells homes in South Africa, what they want to be able to do is say to their rich clientele, look at how good this security system is. Look, here's the cameras, the guards, the,
所以你只需要比他们更好就行了。或者我想另一个类比是，你知道的，如果有狮子在追你，你只需要成为跑得倒数第二慢的人，你知道的？嗯，这里有一个……我喜欢房屋和狮子的结合。让我们用南非房屋的比喻吧。好的。所以南非的房屋安全非常重要，因为在那里，入室抢劫是一个非常严重的问题。所以我们真正讨论的是，在南非卖房子的人，他们希望能够对他们富裕的客户说：“看看这个安全系统有多好。看，这里有摄像头、警卫、
uh, the walls, the doors, whatever. Whereas most people are like, yeah, this is a secure house. That's a really, really big difference. Someone who's like, I put some locks on the thing versus someone who's like, let me walk you through the many ways we thought about security, built it into the design and then executed on it and then improved upon it throughout the build process. That's really the key. And so to your original question, how do we get started? Once we define the goal, we help reshape what's the best way to achieve the goal. Then we define what the scope of the project is. Are we talking about, let's say it's a web app, are you talking about just the front
墙壁、门，等等。”而大多数人只是说：“是的，这是一栋安全的房子。”这是一个非常、非常巨大的差异。一个说“我在东西上加了几把锁”的人，与一个说“让我带你了解我们在设计时对安全进行的种种思考、如何将其构建到设计中并在整个构建过程中执行它以及对其进行改进”的人，有着天壤之别。这才是真正的关键。所以回到你的最初问题，我们如何开始？一旦我们确定了目标，我们就会帮助重塑实现该目标的最佳方式。然后我们定义项目的范围。我们讨论的是，假设这是一个网络应用，你讨论的只是前
end? Are you talking about the back end? Are you talking about both? Are you talking about just the front end. You're talking about the back end. You're talking about both. You're talking about any integrations with other third-party systems. Then we go about actually looking at items within scope and trying to determine, well, how would someone break this? And where there's areas that might be of concern, we'll dig a little bit deeper to actually determine, can you exploit it? And anywhere that the answer is yes, now we actually will build a proof of concept, like how would it work? Not build it, like actually go run and execute it, but we would show here in the code is where the issue lies. And then we tell them, here's how you fix it. They go and fix it. And then we come back and verify, did that fix actually work? So that they can now turn around and turn to their
端吗？你讨论的是后端吗？你讨论的是两者吗？你讨论的是与第三方系统的任何集成吗？然后我们着手实际查看范围内的项目，并试图确定：嗯，别人会如何破解这个？在可能有问题的地方，我们会深入挖掘，以实际确定你是否能利用它。在任何答案为“是”的地方，我们实际上都会构建一个概念验证（proof of concept）——它是如何运作的？不是去构建它，而是实际去运行并执行它，但我们会展示代码中的问题所在。然后我们告诉他们：“修复方法是这样的。”他们去修复它。然后我们回来验证：这个修复真的起作用了吗？这样他们就可以回过头来对他们的
customers and say, not only did we do some security testing that you asked for, Mr. or Mrs. customer, but look at how deep we went. Look at all the issues we found. Look how we resolved them. Here are the ones we didn't resolve yet. And here's why we're not going to resolve them. It's a much more powerful position to talk to your customer when you've actually done it right. Then when you're trying to be really hand wavy and smoke signals and, you know, hope they stop asking questions because if there's one thing that makes people ask more questions, it's when they feel like that the person they're asking questions of is being evasive. Sponsor for today's show is Imparticle. At the end of the day, your customer has to be at the center of everything you do. This starts with the right customer data strategy, as well as the
客户说：“客户先生或女士，不仅我们做了你要求的安全测试，而且你看我们深入到了什么地步。看我们发现了多少问题。看我们是如何解决它们的。以下是我们尚未解决的问题，以及为什么我们不打算解决它们。”当你真正把事情做对时，用这种姿态去和客户对话，要强有力得多。而如果你只是含糊其辞、打马虎眼、放烟雾弹，你知道的，指望他们别再问问题了——因为如果有什么事情会让人们问更多问题的话，那就是当他们觉得被提问的对象在敷衍时。今天节目的赞助商是Mparticle。归根结底，你的客户必须成为你所做一切的核心。这始于正确的客户数据策略，以及
right foundation to solve the challenges that typically inhibit success, such as data quality, data governance, and connectivity. Imparticle is your real-time customer data infrastructure that helps accelerate your data strategy by cleansing, visualizing, and integrating your customer data from anywhere to anywhere. Ultimately, better data leads to better decisions, better customer experiences, and better outcomes. Some of the best brands in retail, financial services, hospitality, media, travel, gaming,
解决通常阻碍成功的挑战（如数据质量、数据治理和连通性）的正确基础。Mparticle是你的实时客户数据基础设施，它通过从任何地方到任何地方清洗、可视化和整合你的客户数据，帮助加速你的数据策略。归根结底，更好的数据带来更好的决策、更好的客户体验和更好的结果。零售、金融服务、酒店、媒体、旅游、游戏等
and many other industries have chosen MParticle. Learn more by visiting www.mparticle.com. Better data, better decisions, better outcomes. Visit MParticle.com to learn how teams at Postmates, NBC Universal, Spotify, and Airbnb use MParticle's customer data infrastructure to accelerate their customer data strategies. I worked on, well, I built this thing called Eternal Terminal, which is like an SSH replacement. That's my one foray into doing like C++ and kind of low-level unix stuff and um and an ethical hacker reached out to me with an exploit uh it ended up not being that big a deal basically uh it lets you masquerade
许多行业的许多顶级品牌都选择了Mparticle。访问www.mparticle.com了解更多信息。更好的数据，更好的决策，更好的结果。访问Mparticle.com，了解Postmates、NBC环球、Spotify和Airbnb的团队如何利用Mparticle的客户数据基础设施来加速他们的客户数据策略。我曾致力于——嗯，我构建了一个名为“永恒终端”（Eternal Terminal）的东西，它有点像SSH的替代品。那是唯一一次我涉足C++和底层Unix相关的东西，然后
as another user but not root maybe or no even that is more than what it did anyways it was not oh no here's what it was you could basically crash the equivalent of like the ssh server and that would kick everyone else off that's basically what it so so at any point in time you could run this and everyone would get kicked out of the server they'd all have to log back in so effectively like a denial of service in a sense or at least yeah make service painful exactly it's exactly denial of service and and sense, or at least make service painful. Exactly. It's exactly a denial of service. And the person, they're super professional about it. They actually reached out to me in an email. They didn't make an issue on GitHub, which would have just told everybody. And they gave me literally a Python script. And I didn't even know some of
有一个道德黑客联系我，带了一个漏洞。结果证明这并不是什么大不了的事。基本上……它允许你伪装成另一个用户，但可能不是root权限，或者甚至连这个都算不上，总之它所做的事情远不止这些。不管怎样，这不是……哦，不，事情是这样的：你基本上可以崩溃掉类似于SSH服务器的东西，这会将其他人全部踢出去。这基本上就是它的作用。所以……所以在任何时间点，你都可以运行这个程序，然后每个人都会被踢出服务器，他们都必须重新登录。这实际上在某种程度上类似于拒绝服务攻击，或者至少……是的，让服务变得痛苦。没错，这完全是拒绝服务。而且那个人……他们对此非常专业。他们实际上是通过电子邮件联系我的。他们没有在GitHub上提交Issue，那样会把事情闹得人尽皆知。他们甚至直接给了我一个Python脚本。我甚至不知道其中一些
these things you could even do them in Python. They're pretty low level networking stuff. But they actually gave me this Python script and I could run it. And sure enough, like it kicked me out of the terminal. And it's just clear as day. And I could, you know, I put in a patch and then I ran with the patch and, you know, the Python script didn't do anything. But it was just, it was just, it was beautiful. Like kind of the way it worked, it was repeatable. It wasn't like a suggestion or, oh, this happened when, or I was able to do this to your point, like with the Olympic skater,
东西你甚至可以用Python来做。它们是相当底层的网络相关东西。但他们实际上给了我这个Python脚本，我可以运行它。果不其然……它把我从终端里踢了出来。这简直一清二楚。然后我……你知道的，我打了一个补丁，然后带着补丁运行，你知道的，那个Python脚本就什么也做不了了。但它就是……它太美妙了。它的工作方式、它是可重复的。它不是那种猜测，或者“哦，当……时发生了这种情况”，或者“我能够对你做到这一点”——正如你所说，就像那个奥运会滑冰运动员一样，
it's like, here's a program and I can run this script and sure enough, it'll do this every single time. And that was a really powerful to see. Yeah. It sounds like you're describing what's called responsible disclosure, which is where a security researcher, an ethical hacker will perform research on an organization. When they find an issue, they'll then submit it to that afflicted organization in order to help them fix it. And then once it's fixed, then they can turn around and write a white paper about it or speak about it at a security conference like DEF CON or something like that. And that is the way that security research is supposed to be done, as opposed to just publishing the issue. But one of the problems that comes up a lot, it sounds like you were very engaged with this researcher who was trying to help you. Yeah, he did tell me that after 60 days, he would publish it externally, which I was fixed long before then, but it kind of did
这就好比：“这是一个程序，我可以运行这个脚本，果不其然，它每次都会这样做。”亲眼看到这一幕真的非常震撼。听起来你描述的是所谓的负责任披露（responsible disclosure），也就是安全研究人员或道德黑客对某个组织进行研究。当他们发现问题时，他们会将其提交给受影响的组织，以帮助他们修复。一旦修复完成，他们就可以回过头来写一篇关于它的白皮书，或者在DEF CON之类的安全会议上谈论它。这才是安全研究应该有的进行方式，而不是仅仅把问题公之于众。但经常出现的一个问题是，听起来你与这位试图帮助你的研究人员进行了非常深入的沟通。是的，他确实告诉我，60天后他会在外部公开，不过我在那之前很久就已经修复了，但这确实
encourage people to upgrade to the latest version when they did find it. Yeah, you have to put the shot clock in there because otherwise you'd be surprised how many companies, despite receiving these known issues, won't do anything. And that hamstrings the researcher a little bit, because first of all, the issue is not getting fixed, which is the real problem. But then researchers are essentially compensated in one of two ways, financially or through recognition. And so financially would be where that's the business, right? So I've talked before about how companies hire us. That's the business. Someone will pay us to do a project for them. But the condition is, of course, this is private to them.
鼓励了人们在发现最新版本时去升级到最新版本。是的，你必须在里面设定倒计时闹钟，否则你会惊讶地发现，尽管收到了这些已知问题，有多少公司依然什么都不做。这在一定程度上束缚了研究人员的手脚，因为首先，问题没有得到解决，这才是真正的痛点。但随后，研究人员基本上通过两种方式之一获得报酬：经济上的或是通过认可。经济上的报酬就是那种商业模式，对吧？所以我之前谈过公司如何雇佣我们。这就是商业模式。有人会付钱让我们为他们做一个项目。但前提当然是，这些对他们来说是保密的。
There is non-disclosures. We don't talk about this to anybody. Occasionally, we'll talk about broad strokes of a story, but no one's identified. No technology is identified. So that's one way you're compensating. Someone pays you to do it, but it's kept private. The other way is you don't get paid for it, but you can talk about it. And talking about it does a lot of things. It helps advance the state of the industry. It helps educate other researchers. It takes a researcher's profile and elevates that profile so that they can maybe get a better job or start their own company or just be more prestigious or write a book or whatever they want to do. But the problem becomes when they're not getting paid and they're not allowed to talk about it.
这里有保密协议。我们不会跟任何人谈论这些。偶尔我们会谈谈故事的大致轮廓，但不会指名道姓。不会透露任何技术。所以这也是一种补偿方式。有人付钱让你做这件事，但它是保密的。另一种方式是你得不到报酬，但你可以谈论它。谈论它有很多好处。它有助于推动行业发展。它有助于教育其他研究人员。它能提升研究人员的知名度，这样他们或许能找到更好的工作、创业，或者变得更有声望、写书，或者做任何他们想做的事。但问题在于，如果他们拿不到报酬，又不被允许谈论这件事。
And so that's why responsible disclosure has to have a shot clock on it, because otherwise the companies could just not do anything. And now both sides kind of lose because the company doesn't do anything. The researcher's like, when is appropriate for me to talk about this if the company doesn't know? Now at least the company's been notified. And when they go talk about it, they won't disclose the actual attack script if the company hasn't fixed it, because that would just be irresponsible. Yeah, totally makes sense. Totally makes sense. I think some things might be somewhat nebulous too. Like in this case,
这就是为什么负责任的披露必须设定一个倒计时期限，因为否则公司可能什么都不做。现在双方都有点吃亏，因为公司什么也没做。研究人员会想，如果公司不知情，我什么时候谈论这件事才合适？现在至少公司已经得到了通知。而且当他们去谈论这件事时，如果公司还没有修复漏洞，他们是不会透露实际的攻击脚本的，因为那样做太不负责任了。是的，完全说得通。完全说得通。我觉得有些事情可能也有点含糊。就像在这个例子中，
it was a pretty deterministic thing. You could just run it and boom. But in some cases, it might not work every time. Like it might be something that's based on some context that's difficult to reproduce. And so the company might not know they fixed it 100%. They might not know if they fixed 90% of the cases or 100%. And so they might have this, the company is going to have a strong incentive for that reason, at least for that reason, not to disclose it. But as you said, that then you have this problem of we can't really tell who's out there doing great work in the security space. So I've heard a lot about DEF CON. I've had friends who go every year and they're super into it.
这是一个相当确定的事情。你运行一下，然后就搞定了。但在某些情况下，它可能无法每次都奏效。比如它可能基于某些难以复现的上下文。因此，公司可能不知道他们是否百分之百修复了。他们可能不知道自己是修复了 90% 的情况还是 100%。所以他们可能会有这样的情况，出于这个原因，至少出于这个原因，公司会有强烈的动机不去披露它。但正如你所说，这样一来，我们就会面临这样一个问题：我们无法真正辨别谁在安全领域做出了出色的工作。所以我听过很多关于 DEF CON 的事。我的朋友每年都去，他们对这个超级热衷。
Can you explain DEF CON? I've never been. So can you explain DEF CON or not to like put your phone in airplane mode because everyone gets hacked. Like, are these, how much of these are fantasy? How much of these are real? There's, well, there's a combination of the two. They are very real. That stuff happens at DEF CON.
你能解释一下 DEF CON 吗？我从来没去过。所以你能解释一下 DEF CON 吗？还是说别把手机调成飞行模式，因为所有人都被黑了？这些传言，有多少是幻想？有多少是现实？这里，嗯，两者结合。它们非常真实。这种事确实在 DEF CON 上发生。
But it's, I wouldn't say it's fantasy. It's not like you walk into the convention center and you're hacked immediately, but it is definitely the place you want to proceed with extreme caution in terms of your technical life or your technology life. Yeah. So DEF CON is, it's a security research conference. So it's for researchers. And that's an important distinction because I think when most of us think about security conferences, we think about things that are more commercialized, like an RSA or something like that. Maybe if there are students listening who haven't been to conferences at all, maybe you aren't more about the business of security, DevCon is really all about the security research itself. It's where new research is published. It's extremely technical.
但这，我不会说是幻想。不像你走进会议中心就会立刻被黑，但它绝对是一个在你的技术生活或科技生活方面需要极其谨慎的地方。是的。所以 DEF CON 是一个安全研究会议。所以它是为研究人员准备的。这是一个重要的区别，因为我认为当我们大多数人想到安全会议时，我们会想到那些更商业化的会议，比如 RSA 或类似的东西。也许如果有学生在听节目，他们根本没去过会议，也许你对安全商业不太了解，而 DevCon 真正关乎的是安全研究本身。它是发布新研究的地方。它技术性极强。
So if you don't have interest in learning the technical side, you might have a difficult time there. But it's all about breaking things. And it truly is a community. I mean, like any community, there are people who are jerks and, you know, arrogant and stuff like that. But for the most part, I find that the DEF CON community is people who are very supportive of each other. They're all there to learn. They feel comfortable amongst each other. I mean, it really does. Community is the right word, I think, for what is a very, very large conference. And, uh, yeah, hot new research gets dropped all the time.
所以如果你对学习技术方面没有兴趣，你在那里可能会觉得有点困难。但它的一切都围绕着破解事物。而且它确实是一个社区。我的意思是，就像任何社区一样，里面也有混蛋，你知道的，傲慢的人之类的人。但大多数时候，我发现 DEF CON 社区的人们都非常相互支持。他们都在那里学习。他们在彼此中间感到自在。我的意思是，确实如此。社区这个词，我认为对于一个非常非常大的会议来说是再合适不过了，而且，呃，是的，热门的新研究随时都在发布。
Like here's the newest way to attack a solar array or a satellite or, you know, cars or stuff like that. Um, we organized part of it. They have this concept at DEF CON it's called, it's a, they call it the villages and there's the villages are kind of like a conference within a conference where it's focused on a particular area. And we run one that's focused on Internet of Things and all the software that surrounds the Internet of Things. And yeah, it's just a cool place to learn and to meet people and hack stuff and meet other hackers.
比如，这是攻击太阳能电池阵列、卫星或汽车等事物的最新方法。呃，我们组织了其中的一部分。DEF CON 有一个概念，叫做，他们称之为村庄（villages），这些村庄有点像会议中的会议，专注于某个特定领域。我们运营了一个专注于物联网以及物联网周边所有软件的村庄。是的，这只是一个学习、结识人们、破解东西以及结识其他黑客的好地方。
And it's just it's it's a cool vibe very cool so i definitely want to dive into um is uh is e and uh you know the company and and how um you know uh you know what positions you have available and all that but before we jump into that what are some kind of uh like a like, you know, piece of advice you could give to people who don't want to get hacked? You know, so this could be, you know, professional, you know, people who are developers, but it could also be just people out there who have a cell phone and they're worried about getting hacked or they hear about their friends getting hacked. What is sort of like some advice you would give to people like that? So the question is advice for individuals as opposed to advice for companies or software
这只是一种很酷的氛围，非常酷，所以我绝对想深入探讨，呃，e 和，你知道的，这家公司，以及，你知道的，你们有哪些空缺职位之类的事情，但在我们深入探讨之前，对于那些不想被黑客攻击的人，你能给出什么样建议呢？你知道，这可以是，你知道的，专业人士，比如开发人员，但也可以是那些拥有手机、担心被黑或者听说朋友被黑的普通人。你会给这样的人什么建议呢？所以问题是给个人的建议，而不是给公司或软件
development teams and things like that. Right. So this would be, you know, if it could be someone writing software on their side, let's say a college student or something like that, but this would be a sort of non-enterprise folks out there. What would be advice to them if they are worried a lot about this stuff? Yeah. So a lot of the common advice that you'll hear around this question is things like, first of all, just be aware, right? That that's first and foremost, you want to be aware. So that means things like, uh, being cautious of clicking links or downloading attachments that come your way. Uh, I re you, you mentioned at one point that you received a text message and I assume it had like a link in it or something,
开发团队之类的建议。没错。所以这可能是，你知道的，如果是一个在自己那边写软件的人，比方说大学生或类似的人，但这会是针对非企业人员的。如果他们非常担心这些事情，你会给他们什么建议？是的。你会听到很多围绕这个问题的常见建议，比如，首先，保持警惕，对吧？这是最重要的一点，你希望保持警惕。这意味着要做一些事情，比如，呃，对点击链接或下载你收到的附件保持谨慎。呃，我重新，你曾提到过你收到了一条短信，我猜里面大概有个链接或者别的什么，
some sort of request. Yeah. Yeah. So like anytime something like that you received a text message and I assume it had like a link in it or something, some sort of request from a person with authority. Yeah, so like anytime something like that, just delete those things or better yet report if you are at a company that has any sort of IT or ideally security team, send that to them so they can hunt it down. But so many of these attacks originate
某种请求。对，对。所以就像任何类似的情况，你收到了一条短信，我猜里面大概有个链接或者别的什么，某种来自具权威性的人的请求。对，所以就像任何类似的情况，直接把这些东西删掉，或者更好的是，如果你在一家有任何 IT 部门或最好是安全团队的公司工作，把这个发给他们，这样他们就可以去追查。但许多这类攻击都源于
from things like text messages or emails that have attachments or links. So being aware of that kind of stuff, being aware of how authorization is typically given. So for example, I still think it's pretty funny the way that doctor's offices operate right now. They call you and they're like, Hey, is this, you know, is this Ted? And I say, yeah. And they're like, all right, well, we just, we just need to verify that you are who you say you are. So can you give me your social security number? And I'm like, no, you verify yourself. You just called me. Yeah. Right. And so even though that one, that is actually the way most doctor's offices operate, which is ridiculous, still push it back on them. They have to prove that they are, in fact, your doctor before you give them any information.
诸如带有附件或链接的短信或电子邮件之类的事情。所以要意识到这一点，了解通常是如何授予授权的。例如，我仍然觉得医生办公室现在的运作方式非常搞笑。他们打电话给你，问：“嘿，是，你知道的，是泰德吗？”我说：“是的。”然后他们说：“好的，嗯，我们只是，我们只需要验证你就是你所说的人。所以你能把你的社会安全号给我吗？”我说：“不，你自己验证。你刚给我打的电话。”是的。没错。所以尽管那个，这其实是大多数医生办公室的运作方式，这太荒谬了，但还是要顶回去。在向他们提供任何信息之前，他们必须证明自己确实是你的医生。
So just being aware that we live in kind of a hostile world and being aware of, yeah, attacks are coming, whether that's clicking links and downloading attachments are the biggest things and forwarding that information to someone who can uh couldn't help with it if you don't have someone to forward it to at least just delete it don't don't do anything with it if it's something that matters you'll find out about it like it won't it won't be the end of the world if you deleted a link that was like oh i was supposed to have that because that person will probably call you and be like hey i set the thing did you we got to sign this contract for this thing or whatever, you know, you're trying to sign a mortgage. Like it would, you'll figure it out. Yeah. Really good advice. Yeah. I mean, I know my wife and I constantly get calls from
所以只要意识到我们生活在一个有点敌意的世界里，并且意识到，是的，攻击正在来临，无论是点击链接还是下载附件都是最重要的事情，并将这些信息转发给能够，呃，如果找不到人帮忙，至少把它删掉，不要对它做任何处理。如果是重要的事情，你会发现的——如果你删除了一个本该收到的链接，世界也不会毁灭，因为那个人可能会打电话给你，说：“嘿，我发那个东西了，你收到了吗？我们得签这份合同，或者别的什么，”你知道的，你正试图签署一份抵押贷款。就像这样，你会弄明白的。是的。非常好的建议。是的。我的意思是，我和我妻子经常接到
the quote unquote IRS, you know, and they're like, you, uh, you owe us a bunch of money and, uh, they're totally fake. I mean, that's a a that's i think the irs scam is now probably one of the most common um um you know we we looked it up once and there's just website after website after website telling you all about the scam and how it works and everything um but uh other scams that you know if we're talking about maybe college students or younger audience there's two others to be aware of that are really, really effective. And you can pick them out pretty easily, but they're still really effective. So one is similar to the IRS scam that says, hey, you owe back taxes or whatever. It's about student loan
所谓的美国国税局（IRS）的电话，你知道的，他们说：“你，呃，欠了我们一大笔钱，”而且，他们完全是骗子。我的意思是，那是，我认为 IRS 骗局现在可能是最常见的，呃，你知道的，我们曾查过一次，那里有一个接一个又一个的网站，向你详细介绍这个骗局及其运作方式等等，但是，呃，如果你谈论的是大学生或年轻受众，还有另外两个值得注意的骗局，它们非常非常有效。你很容易就能识破它们，但它们依然非常有效。其中一个类似于 IRS 骗局，说：“嘿，你欠了补缴税款”之类的话。它是关于学生贷款
debt. And so I fortunately don't have student loans anymore. I paid them off already. So that's how I know these are scams. They're like, oh, your, your loans are in default or whatever. And so every time I get them, I'm always looking at them and I'm like, how, you know, how does this work? What's what psychological tools are they trying to use? I mean, I probably get one or two of those calls a day. And so that's a big one. Be aware of like, if you're getting calls, especially if they seem really urgent and scary about your student loans, just go to whoever you have your loans with and call them directly and ask. Don't respond to someone who's contacted you. The second one that's really, really effective right now is these housing scams on Craigslist, especially if you live in a hot market. So if you're listening to a podcast like this and you're trying to get a job in tech, you're probably going to wind up in like San Francisco or New York or Los Angeles, Austin, these places that rent is really high, places are gone before they even hit the market. And so it can be really tempting when you find a place on Craigslist and it's like, wow, that's in
债务的。幸运的是，我没有学生贷款了。我已经还清了。这就是我怎么知道这些都是骗局的原因。他们会说：“哦，你的，你的贷款违约了”之类的话。所以每次我接到这些电话，我总是看着它们想：“你知道，这是怎么运作的？他们试图使用什么心理工具？”我的意思是，我一天大概会接到一两个这样的电话。所以这是一个大招。要注意，如果你接到电话，特别是如果它们看起来非常紧急、吓人，是关于你的学生贷款的，直接去找你的贷款发放机构，直接打电话问他们。不要回复那些联系你的人。第二个现在非常非常有效的骗局是 Craigslist 上的租房骗局，特别是如果你住在热门市场的话。所以如果你在听这样的播客，并且正试图在科技行业找工作，你可能会最终去到旧金山、纽约、洛杉矶、奥斯汀这些房租非常高、房子还没上市就被抢光的地方。所以当你在 Craigslist 上找到一个地方，心想“哇，这在
my budget. It's even a little nicer than my budget. Oh, wow. Look at that. They replied to me. Oh, wow. They didn't need a background check. All I need to do is send my first month's deposit, security deposit, first month's rent, and this is mine. They'll mail me the keys.
我的预算之内。甚至比我的预算还要好一点。哦，哇。看那个。他们回复我了。哦，哇。他们甚至不需要背景调查。我只需要寄第一个月的押金、安全押金、第一个月的房租，这就是我的了。他们会把钥匙寄给我。”
Oh, yeah. Yeah, don't do that. People who rent you places, even if they'll send in the scams really effective because they'll send you what looks like a really legitimate contract, a lease contract. Yeah. And you're like, well,
哦，是的。是的，别这么做。那些把房子租给你的人，即使他们会寄，这个骗局也非常有效，因为他们会寄给你一份看起来非常合法的合同，租赁合同。是的。然后你会想：“好吧，
how am I going to get housing? If I don't, it might even be a place that's, that's being rented. Cause you could just go on Zillow and find a place for rent and say, yeah, this is me. Right.
如果我不这么做，我要怎么找到住房？”它甚至可能是一个正在出租的房子。因为你只要上 Zillow 就能找到一个出租的房子，然后说：“对，就是这套。”没错。
Totally. Totally. Yeah. They'll always, there'll always be a story like, Oh, I can't show it to you because I'm deployed overseas or I had to go take care of a sick family member,
完全正确。完全正确。是的。他们总是，总会有一个故事，比如：“哦，我不能带你看房，因为我被派往海外了，或者我得去照顾生病的家庭成员，
but don't worry. I have the keys. I'm going to mail them to you. Just go look at the place from the outside, but I can't let you in. You got to be able to see it. You got to know that this person can let you in. So those are two that I would definitely keep an eye out for that are targeted specifically at a student demographic. Cool. That makes a ton of sense. I saw one that was coming at it from a totally different angle, but it's still hacking based off the way we were talking about it earlier where somebody, someone found a place that had included utilities. So utilities were free. We were included in the rent and they proceeded to set up a Bitcoin mining farm and a laundromat. And so the owner got a $300 electrical bill and $250 water bill the first month. Now, fortunately, you know, they're in the contract. It says you
但别担心。我有钥匙。我会把它寄给你。你只要从外面看看房子就行了，但我不能让你进去。”你得能看到它。你得知道这个人能让你进去。所以这两个骗局我绝对会留意，它们是专门针对学生群体的。酷。这太有道理了。我见过一个从完全不同的角度切入的骗局，但根据我们刚才的讨论，它仍然属于黑客攻击，即某人找到了一处包含水电费的房子。所以水电费是免费的。包含在房租里，他们接着建立了一个比特币矿场和一个自助洗衣店。因此，房东在第一个月收到了 300 美元的电费账单和 250 美元的水费账单。现在幸运的是，你知道的，合同里写着你
can't run businesses, you know, it's meant for living. And so I'm pretty sure that they're, the owner is able to, to, to take care of that. But that's, that's, that's also an example of, of, of hacking where you kind of, you know, the, the included utilities, you know, was, was kind of not meant to include you like running your own laundromat well that's definitely an example yeah of someone who said well how can i you know make the intended use of this system be different and so yeah they found that there was contract language it sounds like that prevented that but i even applaud that person they're like whoa utilities are included hold on a a second. Yeah, that's pretty clever. So cool. So let's jump into ISE. So ISE.io is the website.
不能经营企业，你知道的，这里是用来居住的。所以我很确定，房东能够，能够，能够处理这件事。但这也是一个，黑客攻击的例子，你某种程度上，你知道的，包含的水电费，你知道的，本意可不包含让你去开个自助洗衣店。嗯，这绝对是一个例子，是的，有人说：“嗯，我怎样才能让这个系统的预期用途变得不同呢？”所以是的，他们发现合同里似乎有防止这种情况的语言，但我甚至为这个人鼓掌，他们会想：“哇，包含水电费，等一下。”是的，这相当聪明。太酷了。那么让我们进入 ISE 吧。所以网站是 ISE.io。
And it's a, I guess it's a group of folks who assist other companies with security issues. Is that correct? Yeah. Yeah. So we're a company of maybe about 50 people or so today and growing. And yeah, essentially companies hire us when they're trying to understand what their security flaws might be in a given system and how can they improve them? And so basically we hack stuff all day and it's really rewarding in fact, to see, you know, when people find out about our company who like, that's what they want to do with their free time on the weekend or whatever. And they're like, this exists as a job or like, yeah, you got to do bad guy stuff and don't go to jail. So it's great. Very cool. So for folks who are super into this space and would love to kind of work with you,
这是一个，我猜这是一群协助其他公司解决安全问题的人？是这样吗？对。是的。所以我们是一家大约有 50 人左右的公司，目前还在不断发展壮大。是的，基本上，当公司试图了解某个系统中可能存在哪些安全漏洞以及如何改进这些漏洞时，就会雇用我们。所以基本上我们整天都在破解东西，事实上这非常有成就感，当人们发现我们的公司时，他们会觉得：“这正是他们在周末空闲时间想做的事，”他们会问：“这竟然能成为一份工作？”就像：“对，你得做坏人的事却不用坐牢。”所以这太棒了。非常酷。那么对于那些对这个领域超级热爱并且很想和你们一起工作的人来说，
what sort of positions you have? Do you do internships? Is it full-time? Where are these positions located if they're not remote? And yeah, what are some of the details there? Yeah, we have a lot of jobs that we're hiring for right now, ranging from security analysts to we have some, I believe we have some project manager type positions. We have some software developer positions that we're looking for. And there's probably some operational or administrative type jobs as well. We're headquartered in Baltimore. We actually came out of the PhD program at Johns Hopkins.
你们有什么样的职位？你们招实习生吗？是全职的吗？如果不是远程的，这些职位在哪里办公？是的，有哪些细节可以透露？是的，我们现在有很多招聘职位，从安全分析师到，我们有一些，我相信有一些项目经理类型的职位。我们有一些正在寻找的软件开发人员职位。可能还有一些运营或行政类型的工作。我们的总部设在巴尔的摩。我们实际上是从约翰·霍普金斯大学的博士项目发展而来的。
And our West Coast office is in San Diego. But we already had a pretty liberal remote work sort of situation before the pandemic. And then as we've been polling our people as pandemic seems to be winding down, who knows if it is or not. But I think the general consensus is everybody wants to have a hybrid work environment. And some people want to be fully remote. And so whether people want to be fully in the office fully remote or hybrid we support all of that um within the united states
我们的西海岸办公室在圣地亚哥。但在大流行之前，我们就已经有了相当宽松的远程工作环境。随着我们在大流行似乎正在接近尾声时对员工进行民意调查（谁知道是不是真的呢），但我想大家的普遍共识是每个人都希望有一个混合办公环境。有些人希望完全远程。所以无论人们是想完全在办公室办公、完全远程还是混合办公，我们都全力支持，只要在美国境内，
uh there's all kinds of visa issues with people outside the united states that we still haven't quite crossed that um barrier yet but within the united states we're good with all those and yeah i mean that's kind of the culture is community. I mentioned that about DEF CON, but that's one of the defining words of what our culture is about is it's definitely a community. It's like the first word in our mission statement is to build a community. And so for that reason, I think a lot of people do like to come into the office. I personally much prefer it to being remote because I want to interact with people, but we're amenable to whatever situations people want.
在美国境外的人会有各种签证问题，我们还没有完全跨过那个门槛，但在美国境内，这些我们都没问题。是的，这种文化就是社区。我提到过 DEF CON，但那是定义我们文化的核心词汇之一，它绝对是一个社区。就像我们使命宣言里的第一个词就是建立一个社区。因此，出于这个原因，我想很多人确实喜欢来办公室。我个人比远程办公更喜欢它，因为我想与人互动，但对于员工想要的任何情况，我们都是通融的。
Cool. That makes sense. And so are there sort of internships or co-ops or is it mostly full-time at the moment? Oh, yeah. I knew that. I was like, there's one more aspect of the question I can answer. Yeah, our internship program is one of our best. I don't know if it's one of our best. There's so many great parts coming. But our internship program is one of our best. I don't know if it's one of our best.
酷。这说得通。那么现在是有实习或带薪实习项目，还是目前主要招全职？哦，对。我懂了。我就像是在想：“这个问题我还能回答最后一个方面。”是的，我们的实习项目是最好的之一。我不知道它是不是最好的之一。有太多精彩的部分要来了。但我们的实习项目非常健全。在任何时候，我们都会有一名或几名实习生。显然，他们有点遵循实习周期，比如通常是夏天。但我们的实习生经常发生的情况是，一旦他们在我们这里开始实习，他们通常会——他们不会回去，我的意思是，他们会回学校，但他们继续工作，
There's so many great parts coming. But our internship program is very robust. At any given time, we have one or a handful of interns. I mean, obviously, they kind of follow internship cycles, like typically summer. But what winds up happening with our interns pretty frequently is once they start an internship with us, they usually wind up – like they don't go back to, I mean, they go back to school, but they stay work,
你知道，他们可用的时间变少了。但他们最终会做，你知道的，也许在学期期间做一个项目，然后为冬天再次加大投入，接着在春天做一个项目，然后做夏天。所以这真的很棒。所以他们得到，你知道的，
you know, their availability shrinks. But they wind up doing, you know, maybe a project during the semester and then they'll ramp back up again for the winter and then do a project in the spring and then do summer. So it's really great. So they get, you know,
来我们这里实习的人通常没有任何安全背景。当然有些人有，但实际上计算机科学是我们寻找的最主要的背景。根据工作岗位的不同，如果有些工作我们不需要计算机科学背景。但是是的，我们有实习生，也显然有全职岗位。有一些兼职岗位，偶尔我们会雇佣合同工，但主要是全职员工和实习生。非常酷.是的，这说得通。那么在 ISE 工作有什么独特之处呢？有什么特色，比如可以是
the people who come for our internships generally don't have any security background. Some of course do, but really it's just computer science is the big thing that we're looking for. Depending on the job, if there's other jobs that we don't need computer science background for. But yes, we have internships and also obviously full-time positions. There's a few part-time positions and occasionally once in a while we'll hire a contractor, but it's primarily full-time and interns. Very cool. Yeah, that makes sense. So what is something that makes working at ISE unique? What is something like, it could be the
办公桌的布局。或者可以是，也许你们有一个，每个月举办一次比赛，看谁能破解 Ted 的 iPhone。你知道的，我的意思是，在 ISC 工作有什么不同于其他地方的地方吗？是的。除了我们付钱让人家去黑公司之外。完全没有。文化的独特之处在哪里？是的，我们不是唯一这样做的人。所以我热爱我们文化的一点是，它就像，这只是一些有趣的恶作剧，我们一直在琢磨，你该如何向公司外部的人传达这一点，
desk layout. It could be, maybe you have a, once a month you have a competition to see who can break in a Ted's iPhone. You know, I mean, what is something that makes working at ISC different than working somewhere else? Yeah. I mean, besides that, we pay people to hack companies. Yeah, totally. What's the unique thing about the culture? Yeah, we're not the only ones who do that. So one of the things I love about our culture is it's just like it's just fun shenanigans and we that we kind of grapple with how do you communicate that to people outside the
传达这里是一个有趣的工作场所，人们喜欢彼此合作，这并不是那种人们互相踩着肩膀、背后捅刀子的有毒企业文化。不是的，这是一个社区。我的意思是，这个词是，那是，那是故意的。其中一些体现方式是，我不知道，我们会做很多我认为有趣的科技公司会做的事，比如报销很多餐费，报销很多社交活动。但我们也有一些奖项，既奖励人们做出的严肃贡献，也奖励他们做出的滑稽可笑的贡献。公司里现在有一个人，他创作关于我们文化的表情包的能力简直太神了。就像，你怎么能做到这么精准。
company right that this this is a fun place to work like people like working with each other and this is not your corporate toxic culture that people are like stepping on each other and backstabbing it's not it's like it's, it's a community. I mean, that word is, that's, that is intentional. And some of the ways that that manifests is, I don't know, we do like a lot of the stuff that I think interesting tech companies do, like pay for a lot of meals, pay for a lot of like social events out. But we also have like awards to reward people for both the serious contributions they make, as well as like the goofy and silly contributions that they make. There's like one guy at the company right now who his ability to create memes about what our culture is. It's like, how do you it's so spot on.
我们总是把这些分享给大家。我们有一个——随着大流行期间办公室关闭，情况发生了一点变化——我们有一个所谓的“办公室间差旅预算”。所以每个人每年都有一笔专项资金，无论他们是在巴尔的摩还是在圣地亚哥，他们都可以去另一个办公室访问，建立关系，而且，嘿，如果你想顺便旅个游，也很酷。我们有无限假期，所以人们可以——当我建立这种文化时，我的一大重点是，在我职业生涯的早期，在我出去单干之前，
And we're like always disseminating those to people. And we have a, it's changed a little bit with offices being closed during the pandemic, but we have what we call the inter office travel budget. So like each person has an amount of money every year earmarked so that whether they're based in Baltimore or they're based in San Diego, they can go travel to visit the other office and like build relationships but then also like hey if you want to make a trip around that it's cool um we have unlimited vacations so people can like one of my big things when we were building this culture is i was earlier in my career i uh before i went out and on my own um i worked for a company that their vacation policy allowed two weeks of vacation. And I told them when I signed the thing, I was like, just so you know, I'm going to take more than two weeks.
我曾为一家公司工作，他们的休假政策只允许两周假期。我在签约时告诉他们：“我要让你们知道，我会休假超过两周。”如果你们不给我发工资，那就这样吧。但这对我来说真的行不通。我清晰地记得当时有那种感觉，你知道的，那是我二十出头的时候。我所有的朋友都在结婚。我是少数住在加州的人之一。大家散落全国各地。我清楚地记得，当我必须在周三坐飞机以便及时赶上周六婚礼的周四和周五的活动时，我被搞得很有罪感。当时我想：“等我建立自己的公司时，
Like if you have to not pay me, like so be it. But it's just not going to work for me. And I remember distinctly having this feeling, you know, that was my early 20s. All my friends are getting married. I was one of the few that lived in California. Everyone was sprinkled all over the country. And I remember being made to feel guilty when I had to fly on like a Wednesday so I could arrive in time for the events on Thursday and Friday for the wedding on a Saturday. And I was like, when it's time for me to build my company,
我绝不允许任何人有这种感觉。”所以我们的文化就是：你必须过你的人生，ISE 和你的人生必须融合在一起。你必须做有意义的工作。你必须和聪明、能让你变得更好的人在一起。这就是我们建立的文化，我认为这非常不寻常。是的。我也经历过类似的情况，我加入了一家公司，当时我，我，呃，刚刚完成博士学位。所以我仍然有去参加会议的承诺。因此我不得不去，呃，呃，在入职公司大约两周后去参加会议。结果我不得不陷入了
I will never allow anyone to feel that way. And so our culture is just like, you got to live your life, like ISD and your life have to be integrated. You have to do work that matters. You have to be around people who are smart and make you better. Um, and, and that's, I think the culture that we've built and that I think is very unusual. Yeah. I had a similar situation where I joined a company and I was, I was, um, just finishing my PhD. So I still had a commitment to go to a conference. And so I had to go to, um, um, I had to go to the conference, you know, after being at the company for like two weeks. And so I ended up having to go into like
负假期。所以我发现负假期竟然是真实存在的。所以，我好像有负一个半星期的假。这感觉就像在后台看到米老鼠一样，你知道的，就像一个人摘下面具，你意识到这只是一个穿着米老鼠服装在跑来跑去的人。抱歉，迪士尼粉丝们，我要打破这个幻想了，有点像当你不得不休负假期时，你意识到这只是另一个需要被破解的系统，你知道吗？所以，这感觉很好，只需说：“听着，大家都是成年人。”你知道的，当你需要充电时，诸如此类。是的。我认为我们面临的
negative vacation. So I found out negative vacation was a thing. So, so I'd like negative, like one and a half weeks of vacation. And it just just kind of like seeing Mickey Mouse backstage, you know, like the person takes the mask off and you realize it's just a person running around with a Mickey Mouse costume. It's like, sorry to spoil it for people out there, Disney fans, but sort of like when you have to go negative vacation, you realize that it's just like another system to be hacked, you know? And, and so it's like, it's, it's nice to just say, look, like let's, we're all adults here. You know, when you need to recharge and all of that. Yeah. I think the bigger problem that we
更大问题其实是确保员工会休假，休足够的假，真正抽出时间来休假。就像我总是在我的，在我的汇报体系中——“训斥”也许是个错误的词——但在我的汇报体系内，我总是告诉大家：“嘿，你下周要休假，或者两周，或者接下来的三周，随便什么都行。最好别让我听到你的消息。你最好别去查邮箱，别去回信使软件（Messenger）和所有那些东西。”我想现在大家开始明白了，因为你必须从高层开始切实设定这种基调。
have is actually making sure that people will take vacation, take enough vacation, actually take the time off. Like I'm always berating my, within my reporting berating is maybe the wrong word, but like within my reporting structure, I'm always telling people like, Hey, you're taking the, you're taking next week off or two weeks or the next three weeks, whatever it is. Like I better not hear from you. You better not check in on your email and responding to, you know, messenger and all that stuff. And I think now people are like starting to get it because you have to really set that tone from the top.
没错。而大多数公司的管理层却从高层开始做相反的事，对吧？领导层对发生的事情太投入了，以至于他们愿意在度假时工作。这向其他人传递了一个信号：“哦，度假其实并不是真正的度假。我应该检查电子邮件，尽管我可能，你知道的，正和我的女朋友或男朋友在阿鲁巴岛度假。”不，你必须清楚地传达这一点。而且我认为我们在这方面做得很好。非常酷。是的，我发现作为一名工程师，我可以在度假时写代码。但我作为一个领导者，做出的决策简直糟糕透顶。而且，起初我以为也许是因为我对度假时还联系我的人感到沮丧。但后来我意识到这比那要根本得多。当你度假时，你收到的全都是紧急情况。所以你的视角，你知道的，我有几次
Right. And most companies do the opposite from the top, right? The leadership is so engaged in what's happening that they're willing to work on their vacation. That signals to everybody else, like, oh, vacation isn't really vacation. I'm supposed to be checking email, even though I'm like, you know, in Aruba with my girlfriend or whatever, boyfriend, like, no, that you have to clearly communicate that. And I think I think we're doing a good job with it. Very cool. Yeah, I found that as an engineer, I could code on vacation. But as a leader, I make absolutely terrible decisions. And, you know, at first I thought maybe it's because I'm just frustrated that people are reaching out to me on vacation. But then I realized it was much more fundamental than that. When you're on vacation, you only get emergencies. And so your view, you know, I've taken, it's been a few times where
休假一两个月，你知道的，因为我会把假期集中在一起。所以我会注意到，是的，自我离开后，我看到的只有紧急情况。因此，这是一个压缩的时间线，因为你没有，你知道的，工作满 40 个小时之类的事情。所以感觉一切都在着火，你就会变得非常沮丧。只有在事后我才琢磨明白这一点。所以，是的，我完全想呼应你所说的话。当你度假时，一定要去度假，抽离出来，
I've taken like, you know, one, two month long vacations, you know, because I'll kind of batch it up that way. And so I'll notice that, yeah, while I'm gone, it's just all I see are emergencies. And so, and it's kind of a compressed timeline because you're not, you know, working a full 40 hours or anything. And so it just feels like everything is on fire and you just get really upset. And then only in hindsight was I able to figure that out. And so, yeah, I totally want to echo what you're saying. When you're on vacation, definitely take your vacation, check out,
让那个将要顶替你的人承担那个角色，大放异彩，并且完全脱离网络。完全赞同。我，是的，我强烈同意这一点。而且，我们还必须意识到，我明白我接下来要建议的对于一个可能还在摸索职业生涯、可能处于职业生涯早期的人来说可能像是一个跨越，但事实是，你必须让组织学会在没有你的情况下如何做好你的工作，或者如何完成你到那里的使命。而大多数人在听到这个想法时，都会觉得：“那公司可能会
put that person who's going to backfill you, let them take that role and run with it and shine and just be totally off the grid. Totally. I'm, yeah, I so strongly agree with that. And the, well, we have to also realize, and I get that what I'm about to suggest probably feels like a leap for somebody who maybe is still like figuring out their career, maybe they're earlier in their career or whatever, but is that you actually have to let the organization figure out how to do your job or how to get the job done that you're there for without you. And that most people, when they hear that idea, they're like, well, then the company might
意识到他们不需要我，可能会解雇我。所以我必须向他们展示我很重要。”但事实其实恰恰相反。你需要允许，你需要准备好你的团队。我的意思是，为了拥有像我们这样的无限休假政策，这是必须的要求，你知道的，人们必须尽可能提前通知他们的团队、经理，所有人。他们必须拿出一个计划，比如，“好吧，在我离开之前、离开期间以及刚回来之后会发生什么，我必须准备好谁？我必须向他们提供什么信息？”
realize they don't need me and they might fire me. So I have to show them that I'm important. And it's actually kind of the opposite. Like you need to allow, you need to prepare your team. I mean, that's one of the, to be able to have an unlimited vacation policy like we have, it is a requirement that, you know, people have to notify as in as much advanced notice as they can, their team, their manager, it's everybody. They have to come up with a plan for like, okay, what's going to happen before I leave, while I'm gone, and then right afterwards, who do I have to prepare? What information do I have to give them?
这就是为什么很多人在度假时最终还会查看邮件，因为他们没有这样做，对吧？他们会想：“哦，没有人能做这件事，因为我是唯一能做的人，我是唯一有权限的人。”这真的是非常非常糟糕的规划。而我们必须做的是，我们必须能够装备我们周围的人，让他们在没有我们的情况下也能存活几周。而且，无论你在组织中的级别是从基层员工到首席执行官，这都会使你成为一个更好的团队合作者。它能让你更好地理解流程。它能让系统运行得更顺畅，因为你对其有足够的理解来进行沟通。你可以发现：“我们为什么那样做？我们不需要那个。把它去掉吧。”是的。对于人们来说，说“我将主动做一件事，以便他们没有我也能活下去”可能会让人感到害怕，什么？但相信我，一旦你能做到这一点，它会让每个人的生活变得好得多。
That's why a lot of people wind up checking in when they're on vacation, because they don't do that, right? They're like, oh, no one can do this thing, because I'm the only one who can do it, I'm the only one who has access. And that's really, really bad planning. And what we have to do instead is we have to be able to equip the people around us to be able to survive for like a couple of weeks without us. And that, no matter your level in an organization from entry level to the CEO, that makes you a better team player. It makes you understand the processes better. It makes the systems run smoother because you understand them well enough to communicate them. You can find like, why do we do it that way? We don't need that. Let's get rid of that. Yep. And that can be scary for people to say like, I'm going to actively do something so that they can live without me. Like what? But trust me, it makes everyone's lives so much better once you can do it.
是的，完全，完全同意。是的。我的意思是，这，这，我的意思是，特别是在领导力方面，为了培养下一层级的领导者，你必须取代你自己。所以在这种情况下，这是不言自明的，但是，你知道的，即使作为一名技术领袖或作为一名技术专家，这个道理依然成立。为了构建下一个系统，必须有人接管当前的系统。所以它同样适用。非常感谢你，泰德。这太棒了。我知道有些人在想：“哦，我们为什么不谈谈 SQL 注入？”
Yeah, totally, totally agree. Yeah. I mean, it's, it's, it's, I mean, I think especially in leadership, like for you to build the next layer of leadership, you have to replace yourself. So in that case, it's, it's crystal clear, but then, you know, even as a tech leader or as a, as a technologist, the same is still true. For you to build the next system, someone has to take over the current system. And so it holds true for that as well. Thank you, Ted, so much. This was awesome. I know some folks out there are saying, oh, why didn't we go over SQL injection?
我的意思是，你可以在互联网上读到所有这些东西。而且，正如泰德所说，如果我们从现在起一年后谈论这个，情况就会完全不同。我们还有人在听我们 2011 年的节目，直到今天依然在听。所以，你知道的，我们在节目中所说的，依我拙见，我们在这里所说的是永恒的。它永远都是对的。它是人性的各个方面。而且，泰德，你非常出色地解释了什么是安全、为什么它很重要、它如何崩溃，以及当你加入一个组织来帮助他们时你会做什么。所以我非常感谢你的时间。非常吸引人的内容。务必，你知道的，去看看——帮助他们。所以我非常感谢你的时间。非常吸引人的内容。一定要，你知道的，去看看泰德的书，道德黑客领域的头号畅销书作家。
I mean, you can read all of that stuff on the internet. There is, you know, and, and, and as, as Ted said, you know, if we covered that a year from now, there'd be something totally different. And we get people who listen to our episodes from 2011 and still today. So, so, you know, what we said here, in my humble opinion, we said here is, is timeless. It's always going to be true. It's, it's facets of human nature. And we, uh, uh, you know, Ted, you did a great job of kind of explaining, you know, what security is, why it's important and how it breaks down and what you do when you join, uh, you know, an organization to help them out. And so I really appreciate your time. Fascinating stuff. Um, definitely, you know, check out to help them out. And so I really appreciate your time. Fascinating stuff. Definitely, you know, check out Ted's book, number one bestselling author on ethical
所以一定要去看看这本书。你想给我们简单介绍一下你的书和你的网站吗？人们如何阅读更多关于这方面的内容？人们如何找到你？是的，最简单的事情就是去 tedherrington.com。在那里你会找到基于我们今天讨论的内容你可能需要的一切。所以有关于我的书的信息。它叫《可被黑客攻击》（Hackable）。你可以找到在社交媒体上关注我的地方。你可以直接联系我。如果你需要关于安全测试的建议，如果你想申请在我们公司工作，
hacking. So definitely check out the book. Do you want to kind of give us a rundown of what is your book, your site? Like how can people read more about this? How can people catch you? Yeah, the simplest thing to do would be to go to tedherrington.com. There you'll find anything you could possibly need based on what we covered today. So there's information about my book. It's called Hackable. You can find where to follow me on social media. You can contact me directly. If you need advice on security testing, if you want to apply to work
你需要的一切，只需访问 tedherrington.com。非常酷。再次感谢你来到节目中。超级超级有趣，我真的很感激。我的荣幸。谢谢邀请我。Eric Barno 的音乐，Programming Throwdown 根据知识共享署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。您可以自由共享、复制、分发、传输本作品，进行混音和改编，但您必须对帕特里克和我进行署名，并以相同方式共享。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可发表评论。
at our company, anything you could need, just go to tedherrington.com. Very cool. Thanks again for coming on the show. Super, super interesting. I really appreciate it. My pleasure. Thanks for having me. music by eric barno programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license you're free to share copy distribute, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide an attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在我们的公司，无论你需要什么，只需访问 tedherrington.com。非常棒。再次感谢你来到节目。超级、超级有趣，我真的很感激。我的荣幸。谢谢邀请我。埃里克·巴诺（Eric Barno）的音乐。Programming Throwdown 采用知识共享 署名-相同方式共享 2.0 协议发布。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及混音、改编该作品，但你必须署名我和帕特里克，并以相同方式分享。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。